[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good sea-washed Turner sinister ho job
losses up
[Music]
Oh because with the Asia
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I could make sure that you can take
we got a special guest yes Levon we
didn't wash our hands make sure you got
killer
guess the bill we just wait no sorry
[Music]
can you send me a coupon
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
lavoy king
[Music]
this is null barely barely
okay well barely is different okay music
is muted can you hear him now can you
hear me now am i coming through your
speaker's this is Carol Swan they don't
have their subwoofer hooked up so they
normally hear you say yeah you perfect
King King I who said it was somebody gay
now I say okay it's me okay cool because
the music was muted oh cool thank you
would ask what I didn't know so now I
get the loud music and then when you
only back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right now normally I would say and
we are live but I got a make sure a king
so Adi this y'all folks I can make sure
the gig hear me alright alright alright
so long II think the check it was ago I
see level so I'm assuming we good yes a
check he was informed but um yeah man he
said he can't some I miss now though and
we are laughs welcome to the Isle or
podcast and the Lords of gaming dotnet
episode number 151 and it's another
glorious Sunday we're back at the
roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got Project X cloud
x-box vr backward compatibility and the
latest Nintendo Direct to discuss so we
go get right into it I want to introduce
a Lord whom the IOP is not only proud to
call the true friend to the realm but it
has consistently been a trailblazer for
technical innovation in console gaming
whether it be leadership as a u.s.
Marine or passion for gaming as a whole
this Lord always says a positive example
as a protector of the Xbox realm
introducing the former director of
project planning for Project X Club and
the original project manager Lee
responsible for Xbox backward
compatibility the Great Wall himself
Lord of all things overwatch and the
only Lord to challenge anyone on why NHL
94 is the greatest hockey game of all
time laughs of the state of Washington
by way of shy attempt at making his
return into the realm of the Lord's my
man Lord bills still well how we doing
sir I'm gonna have you like my intro
annual reviews call cog up man I get you
that promotion rubbish long time in the
realm you are Lord at what you do you've
been very busy going on right now but uh
what else been going on as far as game
wise for
no will touch the career stuff what what
would go to a game wise for you
um well eventually I got sucked in the
destiny Wow Exploud is what got me
sucked in I don't people remember I was
I was not gonna play destiny too and
when we started doing the initial
testing for X cloud
fill it tweeted out that he was playing
destiny too on X cloud yes and so I had
to make sure it worked and I got a copy
of the game yeah well you know I
actually did have to test it so I got I
brought it home I was playing it and my
son started playing it was buddies and
he's he's younger so every now and then
he'll asked me to join his clan or join
his parties and help him and his his
friends play and I got hooked again on
the DLC with the first game yeah like
their gunplay is just so good say that
line again about the gunplay
nobody does gunplay better it was
unbelievable how quickly I felt like
every gun you pick up just feels
different but you can tell how it feels
you can tell what you're playing by the
reaction you get in the game without
ever to look at your inventory it's
great khali point valley point now I'm
assuming on overwatch is still going on
in full force
yeah you know I was gonna I was gonna
stream a whole bunch of different games
this week just to help out with
quarantine so I got a mixer like during
lunch and plate I was gonna play my plan
was play something different every day
and I played overwatch I think that is
also I loved the home of watched out cuz
of you you actually cuz I have my issues
over what because you I care for my life
I actually started touching up but I get
it you know say I put more of a Genji
main cause it a ninja thing you know
saying the super blocking that was kind
of cool you know but who do you split
between just character wise well I put a
lot of mysteries just to expand my
horizons but I start with Reinhardt and
I finished the Reinhardt and maybe I'll
throw a Lucio in every now and then
that's what's up man go get it we got a
lot of show and of course you already
know we got the Four Horsemen of gaming
those original Lords in a realm here at
the round table
my co-host with the co knows my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror Lord of reviews and the hop of
the jump both my man
Lord addict how are we doing sleepy
doing pretty good and uh don't give me
that energy down you asleep you asleep
I got you take let's go just bleed and
of course we have the most technical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mister offline
profile Illuminati and lore patron of
the iron bake my man know what sovereign
how we doing trying times and when you
have trying times you always want to go
back to when life was simpler yeah
that's what I did
what'd you do what'd you do what'd you
take it back to oh you know what I took
it back to baby let's go let's talk
about the dog system of all time wait
wait we think it's matter we put the
Saturno mindfulness data now that's a
bit much okay the mole dragon remake is
in the bill bro because we gonna be late
with a teakettle directors muse you go
party kick it out of Gubbio say we go
for it we come to drag the Sega Saturn
you could say they've made a lot of
mistakes with that system but I'm gonna
tell you right now mmm-hmm what that
system was brought to the table in terms
of fighting games and 2d games at the
time playstation couldn't touch like
it's not even close and I absolutely
adored that system I've always been the
type of person that I don't I don't ever
go for the for the obvious the obvious
number one like I just don't it's more
fun that way like we grew up Sega kids
you know what that is what it is
Colossus so shaking his head you know
about that life so playing Panzer
Dragoon man I tell you it's the core of
that game still holds up very well it's
a very simplistic unreal shooter but the
world is very beautiful um the action
the things they did to modernize it I
think kind of an sort of iffy I still
prefer to play it like with the old
control scheme yeah but I will say that
I'm glad that it's back
I'm glad other people get to kind of see
where this this disc gone franchise at
this time is is hopefully coming back in
a cool way
if you haven't played the pinnacle of
that franchise which is we can yeah with
this saga right the saga the RPG it's
very portable to get its absolutely but
order order is the pinnacle of that
franchise in terms of the actual just
the shooter part
Zara's an RPG yeah it's on his back
compat on xbox oh please thank you bill
[Laughter]
game is tough and it's fantastic but
parents is back baby oh that's what
service disability smith already earlier
to chat $2 super chat forgive me iron
Lords for I have gamed the Book of X got
the Holy Word out early got description
early listen smoothy smooth I'm gonna
need you to patent that and make sure
that you you get that out the book of X
we gotta give up we gotta get my he's on
to something with that that's all oh man
talk to me i sat down yesterday and I
was like
I gotta get back into the Zelda and ten
minutes in is all it took Oh No yeah oh
it got me again
of course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS game back ooh
the lord of combat sports king of the
statues who demands nothing less than a
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert both Big O beloved Lord
King how you doing sir yes I'm in the
world you see the three people right
listen I know you're gonna go to the
merch store I get that hockey jersey
sorry that's that's no happy for you oh
man um I had to parent that's right I
was gonna do a conjunction video I was
telling cog in the background I said I'm
gonna do it together and i'ma split it
and then I was looking at the box and I
had unboxed it and I said I said you
need your light baby cuz I said I love
the hands and it just it was something
about the mid the the genius of Stanley
the the Majesty the the man was truly
you know I know it's easy to blow it
against some about somebody when once
they pass on right once they transcend
but honestly his legacy his footprint on
this earth I think his foot overlaps to
earth because he's touched everyone
young and old facts and to be able to do
that and in the level of diversity and
it still permeates through the company
his his his blood still pumps through
Marvel it's so amazing
but um check out kos to understand about
that statue see it doesn't be about
really about the statue would be about
my journey into the statue and why I got
said character and stuff like that but
okay so this week what you've been doing
I've been playing like okay so sovereign
talked about Panzer Dragoon right now I
watched a Nintendo Direct am I gonna
live you know I'm going to I'm going to
watch this direct and not fall asleep
I'm gonna watch it right because it was
a stealth little mini direct drop right
and what I like about these companies
what they're doing now well these two
companies because one company shall not
be named um these two companies one is
being an ultra transparent this is a
change of philosophy and I love the
direction right but the other one is
staying true to them right and they're
being in pocket and their pocket is
check this out this is for y'all
here you go and they get straight to the
games and when Panzer Dragoon popped up
yeah I said oh my god and then he was
showing you what it used to look like
because in my head I thought it used to
look like they knew exactly so then I
ran straight to my backpack
shoutout to Bill got that one did you
get that order
clamshell clamp when I was playing X
cloud all right so so now now now and
this is not hyperbole but this week what
I was playing because um in X Box you
have a free to play games for the
weekend sometimes right so one was
modern warfare call of duty the ghost
one and no one to do with the Punisher
dude that's in it only wait okay was he
I thought the punished they do was on
the Rainbow six week ago streetcar and
vehicles alright so okay so I'm playing
that I'm thinking I'm going to be
playing on one player game you know cuz
you know I'm gonna knock it out of like
Jordan through the free weekend you
shout out the Xbox
if you don't got a 4k TV sucks for you
[Laughter]
nothing when I made a dude that look
like me with the scruffy beard and in
the face he just had a scar I don't got
the scar but I said you know what if I
was fighting I will have scar right and
then it got to the part when I made it
to this little city well what am I
supposed to make it to does you go
through this lush jungle area and it
reminds me of wild lands right right
whoa I'm jumping I'm jumping in cause
I'm getting I'm doing crazy stuff don't
I get to this area tell me why it didn't
just turn it to the division
alright pair up with these dudes I saw
oh hell no oh no you know it I mean
maybe you could do some solo stuff but I
just I played destiny too much I'm she's
a fickle lover yes and anytime somebody
dropped something she comes with her oh
here comes iron banner something else
you're fun this out yeah effects ended
children of mortal I can't say it enough
I know a lot of people went and played
the game because of my recommendation
yes it has become one of my top 5 games
of all times that I've ever played in my
life you're talking about a person that
has been gaming since pong since I
hooked pong up
on channel 3 on my RF switch in my house
it's the rabbit is to get it and and and
I played with the paddle I'm you're
talking to that guy that had every
system ever Maybachs ok I was the one
with the Neo Geo's I was the one with
the $250 cartridges I'm telling you this
game from 11 [ __ ] studios and dead mage
I love the story I love what it's about
and I think in this day and age that
story needs to be told it needs to be
felt especially when we wanna just
quarantine stuff listen if you got game
past you'll you're honest quarantine
stuff played again just just boot it up
give it a chance as some people say
stuff like this ain't for me that those
type of games aren't for me let me see
some bro grow out of yourself become a
little bit more than what you're and it
starts with little things like try
something that you may not normally try
don't try shrimp if you allergic to
shellfish trying to be greater what I
want you to do is try something
different don't just go in there just
for the triple-a or the first party
jump-offs try something else that you
normally wouldn't do because I normally
would have never purchased this and I
know you'll see all King is always about
the game this game pass but i'ma tell
you something who did that for you who
want their game pass to you is at a
point right now where this game would
have never got played by me if it wasn't
for game pass if it wasn't for this
service
yo them up with the jab it allowed me to
experience such greatness you
I'm gonna open letter to the studio
because I love it so much real quick
some shout outs I see the Lila Age dear
did chat that's what's going on Lucas
law the in separate ghost is in Philly
Eagle got a shout out my boy rage virus
and quick shout out monkey punch what's
up I gotta say what's up to arm see oh
no she only doors 1212 man last night I
believe midnight he hit me up him and
his wife gave birth to a baby girl
salute man congratulations a new one in
the realm always welcome I'm glad she
get went through safe everything a sound
that's my destiny brethren always in our
discourse so salute to him throw up your
ILP crest for the new one in the round
oh yes yes pity for me I miss that super
Jeff and Smitty Smith and I could see
the speed and power in that statute OB
law kognito spreading that realness in a
Roman IOP I tell you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so yeah
man it's been gaming wise for me it's
been on that animal crossing cake over
rock event of a rocking a little bit of
that shout-out to all pets I mean look
it's a crook
Tommy's a cross believe a shout-out to
Panda it's why so I'm messin around I
don't know anything about the oil on
functionality it sounds like what's this
important thing about so where did you
go fly to an island or whatever I know
nothing I get there pandas dead she
welcomes me at the airport she takes me
to the house and this spot logs in and
then they're doing a housewarming party
she's got like a flue in a guitar and
I'm type I'm like I don't know what I am
doing like you gotta see my clip on my
Twitter right now it's if people are
dying so shout out to the notice he said
he types yes I had today
you know how grandpa who's wearing a
face mask gateway record of like y'all
savages they do the things that you
could create at this game is hilarious
or so
- the oceanographic guard in the
building you already know but I've been
doing that of course that's the there's
some trials this weekend shout out to um
Wilhelm scream you know I'm saying of
course and of course sinister was in it
with me getting our little weapons
together and all that good stuff but uh
that's it so over the net um yeah tough
week initially you know I'm saying my
brother man is his anniversary you know
one year since we all since we lost
whiskey so I just want to shout about
man you know definitely mess brother you
know you touch the soil we still [ __ ] I
can't believe it's been a year and well
it shot up some thought to its family
you know I'm saying
Papa whiskey also the friends Ryan
Stefan and Dylan you know I'm saying
those guys we all stop we want me to
keep it in contact and keep it strong
with that whole situation so long
whiskey rest easy brother you already
know I had one for you yeah this is your
signature ako he's got aka Lord fireball
K Iron Chef will help us down every e3
we definitely everybody bending me you
know saying Lord whiskey like I said
that's my brother we miss you and I just
went to salute you
yeah other than that in a positive note
you know I'm saying we got a giveaway so
shout out to um loss so now though I'll
put it in the chat man if you haven't
seen it already it is up on the iron law
podcast Twitter addict should be very
happy about this because the goal has
returned Final Fantasy 7 remake y'all so
look if you were to get your hands on it
before release your them saying we have
that giveaway going on right now and
yeah check that out sign up dude would
do the do what you need to do but um
yeah that's all I got so we go get into
this man so obviously you guys what the
Lord's are playing Thank You PD
appreciate the late those no um you know
but I'm focused ill well now you know so
his tremendous video game system history
and and its amazing journey was it was
already documented you know same way
back though way back ilp32 you know say
so please check that out on ILP we have
an exclusive interview section on the
YouTube page he's one of our very first
interviews you know say but um we still
got a few gaming history questions for
we ain't gonna let him off the hook it's
been been that long like King said you
know we go back since the RF switches
from channel 3 to 4 we we go back to dot
matrix printers and
printing stuff for green papers you
don't say like that's how far be a
little bit still well go back so um you
know what we gotta ask us some critical
questions though
you know say obviously idiot so we
talked about that NHL 94 and why it is
to go shout out the bat piscatella you
all wrong for now I got a supporter
nobody showed that it was a good game
salute the bat but um yeah and those
amazing Genesis games but what I want to
ask Lord bill what are your other
favorite sports games of all time so
let's start with that
um so I actually used to play both on
the Commodore 64 and then also on the
Apple oh the one on one Jordan versus
bird do they have a adult contest as
well as over time I think I started off
with dr. J versus bird yes
mer imagine the magic or like it just
kept evolving yeah just throw another
one on yeah you got to the poor you
could break the blackboard the janitor
come out so those then the other one we
played many a night in college probably
with shot glasses to the side well the
epic summer and winter games they were
there basically Olympic events right and
okay they weren't great but you would be
like you do like the diving and you'd
hold certain keys down to do different
types of flips and then you'd have to
time it right so you get a clean splash
and then you'd get gold medals or silver
medals depending on how you did used to
play those a ton especially the Winter
Games yes that's the stuff yo Chat Chat
is saying some class they say a double
dribble they say there's some classic
[ __ ] gays go Jewish Oh shadow the tip
diamond with the two our super chat
salute ILP corona gotta do anything make
sure you put the carnivorous in there
don't put that other stuff yes yeah God
is out here oh shout the lost egg all he
says do not blaspheme epochs summer and
windows games remember that one
yeah okay great yeah we got some bogeys
in here that's my man right there shout
the Lord Stig original nlg podcast very
good guys love that so okay so we got
that so we Oh give me some more game it
could be like two more classic there was
like I can't remember the name of it but
there was like a monster football on
Sega oh you're talking about football
yes football yes yes I was very good
like it comes like mechanics it was
great
like it would had like real football
obviously like a potations shout-out to
mr. ha yeah I think mr. ha me mr. ha the
only people that had that mutant league
football so the cardboard box that's
that's the car boy bill they had a
hockey one - you play that as well yeah
they're mutely hockey that's what's up
bang a shot to the chest out James John
Chavis is bringing up their blades of
Steel did you I know you it wasn't you
was Genesis at the top but do you
remember that wouldn't please I remember
blades of Steel oh yeah in fact I've
been playing every now and then I'll pop
in super blood hockey sort of wasn't row
back on the Xbox now you played a PC as
well yeah it's not quite as deep as NHL
but yeah what was what was the n64 I
think it was exclusive that was kind of
like it was like I can be a gem for
hockey Africa clear was a well there was
the three on three three we had it on
Xbox 360 as well it didn't come to the
back of that program early Dan the
Canadian hit the rocks in the dive event
on summer games all the time so clap
people saying RBI Baseball - baseball
stars NHL bleach elastics bases loaded
Lord tipsy I remember that would guys
I love your big J miss Tyson thanks for
the shoutout cake easy to check yeah big
J's my do you already know so now we're
moving on from the sports like that we
already confirmed that a road rash
what's our garden is the Gautreaux rash
of all time we have video there's
nothing even close we've already
concerned that you already got that
determined but we never done ever talk
to you about out to other systems which
was the the Dreamcast and the turbo
graphics 16 did you have either of those
and if so any standouts for you
I had Dreamcast I got I didn't I didn't
actually use it a lot mmm-hmm are
usually mostly for fighting games if
that was a Virtua Fighter was a big deal
too so that was that was sort of the
core and I'm awful at fighting games but
I can't stop playing did you have that
Soulcalibur net walkie of course cuz so
caliber is actually I still play so
caliber I was so disappointed in the
last one not because the gameplay wasn't
good mmm but the one thing I've always
loves about fighting games even besides
the gameplay itself have been the
cinematics that have come along like I
can finish this game you'd finish every
character just to watch yes there's
video story preach and when I heard Soul
Calibur was gonna have more of that RPG
flow I was so excited and it was all
those texts all this time with I was so
upset yeah playing the game yeah me too
yeah it's a disconnect song I agree it's
a disco because you care about the couch
you make that choice you care about the
character you got that emotional
investment so you want to know their
journey and how it affects the end you
know I'm saying and I'm which is yes
it's a Namco staple and it's yeah I
think that's what made Tekken that's
what may because even the characters
that you thought like coma mm-hmm he had
an ending to yeah you can't develop
these characters in in that play style
you just cannot do any kind of story
development like even in overwatch they
can do quips and things on certain match
levels the time back to the videos but
if you don't actually have a video
cutscene for these characters in a
fighting game
there's no development at all and that
disappointed so glad you said that but I
feel you've a lot lot there and it gets
a turbo obviously cuz you a genesis guy
at that time so trouble Robert Zubrin
was missed at that point yeah I just
missed it yeah isn't there one coming
supermini yes for waiting for actually
have it in my in my shopping cart right
now make sure that's the one I ordered
yes yes Jesus it looks like they do it a
really good retro version some nice nice
games nice callback so you don't say oh
we got sue in chat we've missed so saw
if you want to get that or Attica when I
get that I think it's a biggie pixel
busy with the $2 super chat fourth and
inches on the Commodore 64 oh yeah good
game plastic you already know so did
after places I remember you said that
I mean after three do you remember you
said you went to places you any place
things should stand out for you little
bit oh I was I was oh photorealistic
them how it used to look
I still what's the game the song by the
cardigans I can still see that intro
video play every time I hear that music
it just automatically yes and you can
see it Gran Turismo for sure and I was a
I love the ratchet Clank series
[Music]
beautiful Pixar mmm-hmm I mean for all
the talk about Pixar quality games I
think the Ratchet and Clank Clank series
came the closest to that yeah as much as
it seemed like a kids game when you
looked at it the different weapons were
so complex and the stuff you could do in
that game yeah the classic place a place
has some classes where there's no doubt
about Roger Craig was definitely up
there
okay squirrely dan hit the rocks on that
dive event on summer games all the time
oh yeah we got that's what's up you
already know so Lourdes have a great
show game before taste
I heard you guys almost went to the
lighthouse last night on PC shout-out to
gay before I tell you about destiny
Bridgman ya already know I would sadly
never get to the lighthouse you know
what it is you know I do have somebody
right now that you know she is a destiny
beast
so I'm trying all I need is just one
more person because you know I'm waiting
for the series X to come out for
sinister to see the light and bring
yourself oh he's coming right over there
what that 60 frames plus that field is
always gonna be pure I can't wait for my
console Brenda to get that the Tower of
Power so you can understand it but um
yeah man last gaming question I want to
ask obviously you are known for your
overwatch love you know they so little
bit like tell us about that like you
know you know how did that start
and then how excited are you for
overwatch - that's not what to do um I
think for me the game so when that game
first came out I played a little bit I
thought was good and it was nice one of
things I love about it is how committed
Blizzard is to continuing to balance it
so that they're constantly tinkering and
they're always looking for you know you
play these in it you put those first
games and I can remember you play a game
and like there'd be sixth orbs on the
other side maybe trying to get and just
guns everywhere you couldn't do anything
and over time they continued to refine
the gameplay they continued to refine
the character sets and even some cases
change the way the characters play
they're not afraid to take something
you're used to and just doing it over
and making it better
I will say this it goes back to the
story element to it the shorts that
Blizzard did that they put out that non
youtube like I could watch those forever
they are like legitimately good movies
yes the Rhinehart story the bastion
story I'm awful at both Genji and honza
can't play but that that two dragons
video short that they did on those two
yeah where they it was amazing and that
builds these stories then you go play
these games and you know Reapers talking
to widow you know
two characters load in waiting on Kings
Road you hear there have their backstory
and I think to me the way that they
built that world up that's the one thing
Blizzard does I believe better than most
is they just create the entire universe
around their gameplay and around their
stories that just sucks you in and are
you going to continue to know more about
it and the other thing about that game
that I love is it's still popular enough
that you can jump in you can immediately
get into a match you can play with a
group of people even if you solo don't
use a mic there's always people out
there willing to jump in and play and
and the gameplay solo not use their mind
looking for groups is for when you can
you can you can adapts to so many
different styles right if you are good
at first-person shooters you can pick a
soldier you can pick a Reaper if you're
if you're not as good with that kind of
stuff you can picked orb you can pick
Symetra or others and and they can
support any gameplay style if you're not
as good with that you know it's okay the
the overwatch community to be very
supportive in your decision yes it's the
most supportive community no one ever
lets you know that you picked the wrong
care it's like on the road oh it's
pretty bad over there sometimes I will
say this there's like so there's there's
two wait depends on the mood I'm in if
I'm playing calm I'm very specific about
how we're gonna play this game together
not I'm gonna be a nilin and curse you
out but the thing is the reason people
are like that cuz you get really
penalized if you lose and calm learning
it is just like it's just like you ain't
gotta get to it they got four tanks we
don't know what a skip is that and the
first what a game is great I've been a
hater only for the game of the year
talking Game of the Year gonna get me
started
this is a positive section of tried to
give it up try to get praise but here's
the thing the gamers of Maine the only
issue I had as I felt like they had
these amazing characters right and I'm
just like man I would like to know about
them it's like what you say Lord Bill
how there's these amazing shorts that
you say that like outside the game and
it's like I just wish that was in so now
that I heard the announcement for to and
I saw that cinematic and I saw them all
together and I'm like okay this is what
I kind of want to see and I'm just
hoping that you know they continue that
and have that stuff in game because I
really do feel they have great gate now
game characters any game is pretty
amazing what do you feel about that yeah
I think I'll be interesting to see how
well they bridge that sort of PvP to PvE
structure they're doing a little bit of
it they're drawing their archive event
right now which is their aunt one of
their annual events and they have these
co-op modes that you can play or you
just fit you know it's a sort of
portable right you're just facing waves
of waves of enemies and there are a lot
of fun they're just different than the
core gameplay it's it's i watch that
trailer and watch the the initial look
for what PvE is gonna look like for them
and I'm excited but I'm also nervous
because these are talking about combo
moves and like they've already had some
issues with balance on certain
characters and you know and the ability
in PvP to do things like roll key or you
know roll lock you only have two tanks
you only have 2 healers you can only
have 2 DPS and uhero pools lets them
tune that but at the same time I only
want to play as Reinhardt there's a
combination like it's frustrating me and
comp right now with the meta being IRISA
because I really I I don't mind a risk
it right now I want to play right like
[Music]
good character to play it's just it's
not the same kind of gameplay that I
like gotcha come on there's nothing
better than being Reinhardt overcharge
you and you just start swinging that
hammer look all I know is a good
Reinhardt can lead you to victory but a
bad Ryan Hart will make you right to
quit
they do the truck they do charge it's
like there was nothing there Cuchillo
charge is how you move around these
seats in you right now have no idea
behind in realize there's like a Reaper
nah man you don't do that no we're
doomed facism yes yes okay so this the
only reason why I was sent me interested
in that game because Terry Crews are
supposed to be doing well yes that's
what they thought right and then Terry
Crews came out and cracked down I was
like oh all controversy happen but you
know he didn't get that part and he
really wanted that part or whatever so
that made me put on overwatch and as you
just said I learned how garbage I was
but I got the games out the way low
recap you know saying a gimmick for
those that missed you know again I'll be
32 minutes is I Lord bills debut please
check that out he's got tremendous
gaming history
so much to learn ways come from his baby
it's really cool but okay career a bit
you know since you were last here you
were the lord of back then on you
transition to a project planning for
Project X cloud and now potentially a
new role so um I need to set the record
straight
don't IOP you know say we leaving Xbox
and you know where's the great ball
going what does this new role entail
what's going on yes so I am leaving Xbox
that was the hardest part of this
decision for the last so let me back up
a bit while I was working on back compat
my boss at the time Kevin gamble who now
runs our developer program for Xbox he
had said to me hey as we get ready to go
on this was years or years ago he says
we're getting ready to look at the new
generation we want to look at additional
capabilities when I look at ditional
foot additional endpoints so take a look
at the streaming tech
that we've worked on in the past and see
what you think about it so as part of a
sort of employee one on gamestream it
was part of our planning cycle for next
generation I focused that's sort of at
the time a part time job on what it
would take to bring games and make them
playable using Asher's back-end Network
and playing them on any device and I got
prototypes bill gotten thing into the
program and part of our actual next-gen
plans and then sort of summary just
brought that through until we got to the
point where we had released an actual
beta product out into the market people
are trying people are playing it and at
that point I started looking at other
opportunities inside and outside that
Microsoft is just sort of a natural
progression the projects I like to work
on our projects that are technically
complex and more importantly they're
ones that people aren't sure about like
well should we imagine this or not you
know those are that's why I got into the
backpack program I did the console
launch prior to that in China yeah it
was like well we made a console launch
and China work laws have changed let's
give it a try and then now game
streaming with projects cloud absolutely
but we're at a point where the tech
works obviously will continue to refine
it will continue to make it better and
and over time things will improve right
but there's not really much I can do
from a planning perspective there's not
really much I can do as a lead on that
program anymore so I start looking
around and explored a couple different
avenues and in fact thought I was gonna
go down to two or three other paths that
just didn't pan out okay and then I had
initially talked to another group of
Microsoft that runs the hololens program
yes and says it's i am a big believer I
know so catch them some feedback
potentially get it let's do it look VR
and AR is gonna be part of our big part
of our future and I believe that the
tech is right on the cusp of being ready
you know it's sort of like game
streaming you look at game streaming
people when trying to gain streaming
forever yes well yeah dial-up modem that
wasn't gonna be effective you could
barely do a remote desktop fax but over
time technologies improved and and
you'll cross a threshold where a segment
of the population will be able to access
some technology at scale that's enough
to justify the trial of a new business
and then over time as that business
improves you'll get you'll get another
push out into a larger demographic to a
larger market and I think VR and AR mix
reality experiences are in that same
spot so I talked with the it's called
the cognition team at Microsoft talk to
them for a while I like that big circle
back and they said look we think you'd
be a great asset for the team we'd love
to have you interview for a role and
focus on more consumer level mixed
reality services so I accepted that role
a few weeks ago finally and I officially
start there next week but you know with
quarantine everything's been going slow
I have been working with the team now
for a while a little while and I get
spun up and I'm excited about where this
industry is gonna go you know nothing
concrete
right like it you're seeing oculus make
moved your scenes valve make moves and I
just think it's the time oh so history
where it goes this is awesome real quick
oh my got silks a little too loud
subtract question did Erin Giles work on
the back compat team I don't know if I'm
allowed to speak about people's yes so
we will get trouble we won't get your
job yeah no worry about their no worry
about that we got you've got your cover
we protecting the wall
we got a protective wall shadow style up
to the US military Cruz is the man
big-time gamer as well so look let's get
right back into the hololens which is
the new role right everything that
you're doing now and um i got to be
honest like after it's an issue debut
you know I remember seeing it shout to
kudo and those guys also was once I see
it and you know augmented reality seem
to me it seemed very very cool you know
saying I got to admit I remember them
doing this the Xbox stage demo I believe
it was minecraft you know and it has
some really cool scenes with a hollow I
mean a halo kind of like a hollow deck
kind of thing behind closed doors which
I didn't get to see shoutout to Kanye
for taking my spot kind of a salute he
took they can't kudo kitties don't be up
but he's like Brokaw yeah ok I said I
understand that slot was it for me but
um yeah man so look everyone raved the
body I remember a really really strong
review
initially impressions and then it kind
of disappeared and and it kind of went
away from the gamer slash consumer space
and then almost like a commercial only
kind of thing he liked what King says
like that price we saw that price
because my biggest question the bill is
all right I understand technically you
know the magics gee I've seen what you
what your team can do and you in a team
format what what can happen in your
hands and the fact that you said you
like challenging projects that you're
not sure of I love the fact that you
said that because with that back compact
nobody was sure of that and you know you
brought that to reality you know when I
when Lord Bill was talking about you
know I like something that's difficult
something this complex like he's the
tech version of house he's making stuff
that seems impossible possible acts and
in the fact that you're challenging
yourself and you're looking for greater
challenges because like you said the
techs worked you when i sat with you and
we looked at the techie you blew me away
blew me absolutely the way in a sort of
tech and you know people didn't this is
definitely what he does right so when
you know because you know we talked
about in the background oh when you you
know transition or going to some places
like ah man so to hear you say that
you're going to Hollow and I said please
thank God please could he use his
majesty to get that price down so thank
you first obviously I'm more open and
more public there's brilliant people
that I work with that are the ones that
really make this
it's not it's not it's not one
individual it's no one person I've
gotten the opportunity to work with just
some brilliant teams and one of the
things that kept me at Microsoft was
legitimately I sit down to people who
I'm sure are geniuses and I can just get
smarter working with them so you don't
often get to roll with that company on a
daily basis and so I do want to I don't
want people overstate my contribution
fin huge team of great people awesome
the other thing is - yeah by the way I
just stopped for a second what's up
after we did III yes tell me now X cloud
and people played it and I got all these
people telling me well it was a closed
environment okay if you've never worked
networking at a Convention Center
hey don't worst possible scenario yes
I'm glad you we were doing we were
having times where like camera crews
would walk in with their APs and they
just blow the entire stage Network out
what's going on and you're trying to
track them down and it is the and we
have one pipe that everybody's running
whether they're run the gears demo or
they're running some other game
traveling like everything's going
through one final point and the number
of people who were thinking this was the
best possible way it was controlled
build you have any variables like the
millions of people walking around their
personal wireless access point so glad
you said that and people who thought we
staged the whole thing yes they're the
ones that just kind of blew my mind yeah
it was like I said it launched initially
I guess people gonna be scheduled I'm
glad you said what you said it's wrong
as far as taking on projects that most
people think are impossible and
challenging history good I'm saying well
get into the backup app again later and
obviously you know I'm saying Project X
cloud you know that was the day when we
came back from e3 people kept asking us
you know like how wasn't you sure was it
one to one and let me tell you something
when I got addict on my side he's one of
the best people to take when it comes to
showing a developer off sort of game off
he is so blunt like he is
unapologetically blunt
so if your tech don't ya every time I
review something I always put is like
are you sure
so if you remember the bill you gave it
to me and I'm I hold on a D touch this
right yeah cuz he's gonna try to break
it he's gonna see if there's going on if
it and I'm like is it one-to-one is it
old does it feel how does it feel he's
like God no this is this what do you
what he's quiet and the heads down and
he's just it like difficult conquer mode
I'm like yeah is let's talk about addict
talk about it with you goddamn X level 2
first up I definitely like what I liked
about it is like you didn't feel like
you you just felt like you was maybe
like streaming to a tablet or something
on your actual Xbox like he wasn't
actually like just wisely streaming
mm-hmm like it felt nice it did like I'm
still not a big fan of like you know the
whole you know the whole wireless thing
but you know out of all this stuff that
I have truck as I try stadia once
definitely it was definitely the one
that I would be more open to doing that
and that is big for him yes I know how
he is in reference to that kind of tech
he really doesn't really cater towards
that but for him for hit to get the
attic seal of approval I know this is
doable I could play this the latency is
Manorville and you guys have since
improved way since then I mean I was an
early you know why don't you tell him
won't you tell bill exactly how his well
his team well you know the group of
people because we don't like you said
you know anytime I say you like Phil
Dominick Spencer I always try to give it
a caveat like it's a whole big team
behind that stuff right there you happen
to be the face that we are familiar with
right all right when it comes to that
stuff right there so our reference point
is the Great Wall so you know great wall
represents the team you know and in my
opinion Frank so but let me tell you
what your team did in yourself um you
cost me $1,400 oh you
you say that I got a topic for that too
good so it's our saccade so we can't go
regular we gotta go big screens you know
something this is true so in the back of
this joint I have a little you know I'm
a huge multiplayer yeah first so like I
feel like if I got it I would play like
a lot more like XCOM and stuff like that
cuz that stuff I took I guess what it is
it's like I'm one of the I'm a very
competitive competitive right ragged and
I ain't trying to give anyone no advance
so you know to me I've never played you
know X Claude on any kind of multiplayer
game but in the back of my head is like
will be lagging telly I was doing that
whole thing I feel you you to you
experience cuz I don't mentally well
don't you say that no I know is
sometimes when I lose I got that control
of my hand I'm like this I can't have
that thought process to my $700 foam
Xbox has a sleeper cell in the VR space
no doubt man we're gonna touch old man
shout too long Kid smooth
I beat Tekken 7 on Galaxy Tab using X
cloud shout out to elf what a he said
seven
yeah it's an era yeah absolutely except
the four take toilets which I he's right
I feel smarter this is the bill talk
the doubted shadows let's jump right
into the transition with the whole thing
I was super Hollis but with you all been
in reality but then the VR aspect and
specifically Xbox VR you know because um
it's a very spicy topic right now
obviously when um you know the initial
information came out about the series X
you don't feel had to kind of address it
because you know a lot of people who
were little upset with somebody's
initial statements which were kind of
like you know right now you didn't feel
that there was you know a huge demand
for it necessarily for the series acts
initially but then since then it's kind
of clarify these statements and he just
said you know they look he's just trying
to focus right now on gaming initially
right for the series X so I want to
actually then transition to what
obviously what you're in your new role
right and you may some of some
interesting statements a law bill you
said you believe that mixed reality is
the cusp of breaking through to the
masses you said you don't want to miss
out on a chance to help drive this
forward
you said Microsoft has the tools in the
tech and now is the time to put the
effort you know focus it and growing
this space so um that's a lot and then
obviously you know just recently saw an
announcement winner HP and Microsoft and
valve are on on a headset and you know
that got people you know going up like
you know what's going on so there's a
lot to unpack so what I want to ask you
here you know Bill is that obviously
there are is a section of Xbox phase
that are clamoring right for for Xbox to
to go into VR space you know I'm saying
so is it time you know cuz one thing the
one key thing you mentioned you said
consumer space right so is it time that
you know can they finally start getting
a little bit excited based on these
things that you know Xbox may be
pivoting in that direction I wouldn't
make a statement about where Xbox is
gonna fit right I think that the way
this could look about this is that we
already have a business in headsets
inside partners I mentioned HP we had
other partners who produced Windows mix
reality headsets yes that compete with
the HTC vive they compete with oculus
they can beat with with now the index
and I say compete meaning that there
alternatives from a hardware device
perspective and you can go in the steam
store and you can buy games
I don't feel just as I step back and as
a consumer myself I don't feel like
they've really met the capabilities and
that's really what I was trying to get
at and you know we have a rope we have
our own store we have a rich history in
PC game and you're seeing the company as
a whole focus more on PC gaming with
with game paths for PC it's not it's
part of just an overall effort you know
and a touch back on even to go back to
the the streaming thing right yeah some
people aren't ever gonna want to get
away from their 4k there a K TV but
there are other people who never who are
never gonna buy a console now next God
gives them an entry point into a
different type of game you're right I
will say this the very first demo I did
where I was sure that I was on the right
project for streaming was I went down to
the lobby and they got overwatch working
for me absolutely not like I was not it
was not ready for that the audio is out
of sync and it wasn't quite where it
wanted to be but then I played like for
quick play matches in a row and I
realize all of a sudden that this is
where consumers will not necessarily
change who they are but they'll adapt to
new things when video first came out you
look at all the data for when short-form
video came out like the 3G network era
yes everybody well they'll just watch
small videos no one will ever watch a
movie on a phone no one will ever watch
TV series on their phones the point and
now you're at a point where Netflix is
producing Tiger king just for people who
stream contents yeah and you don't think
twice about the fact that streaming my
video to watch this if you've not
watched it's insane show exists entirely
because consumer behaviors change over
the last 10 years I think that X cloud
is a stepping stone towards we're trying
to democratize and make gaming available
and give consumers the choice to play it
on the device they want to play it on
where they want to play it and you may
have the put my headphones on with Dolby
Atmos with my 8k variable refresh rate
screen and go do whatever I want to do a
multiplayer with my wired controller
because I don't need me latency versus
I'm out and about
play a little bit of gaming and so now
you take that and you say okay so what
does that mean that same philosophy and
I can't speak for how the team strategy
is right a group my philosophy here is
the same kind of things gonna happen
with with VR and AR experience pork like
the device prices will come down yes
Mullins has some capabilities it's
become a phenomenal success in the
enterprise in commercial space right and
that's really what sets the price
because the precision needed for that is
different than what a Windows headset or
HTC headset or an oculus headset needs I
get a ton of miles out of the quest and
just because I can untether it and I we
were talking I think before we started
you know we're in quarantine I got to do
something to stay 500 pounds just
something to immerse myself in a new
world even though I'm confined to four
walls facts then you take that element
and you and you overlay what you can do
in the augmented reality space where you
can start to see you know things like
Minecraft earth or Pokemon go where
you're out in the world and I just want
to put overlays in front of you they can
be informative they can beam directions
continue yeah I'm about a oh I like
Riley and we're really close to the
quest I think started it mm-hmm you can
untether and you can bring your power
with you missing the next wave and I'm
not making any kind of statements about
direction or planning but you know
you're starting to see with X cloud you
can offload compute you can offload
processing that's what I said is because
you've got to get the devices to a form
factor in a price point where nobody
thinks about throwing a pair of glasses
on there that's yeah yeah there we go
Cote and now you can have experiences
that are Richard just so like instead of
having to look at my phone when I walk
around a new city mm-hmm I can just
throw the maps up in front of me and I
can see this is where I have to go
I see data about stores that are nearby
you know who has that right we went to
play craft New York and I was using a
Bose headsets the the shades
and yeah they had this there's the
augmented reality city tour yeah now
when you put on the shades you you're
walking around and you're looking and
like you look at the store and it'll pop
up like what's their best item or stuff
like that and this is the train station
and this is going this way and this is
going that way and I said when when when
when tech gets to that point that you're
playing like my thing is X cloud and you
know getting past if I complain off my
gamepad stuff with someplace else when
he gets to that form factor like you
said you put on some glasses and you're
looking at Tony Stark you're looking at
these mom and these guys are trying to
make that a reality and we're talking to
that guy with this team that wants to
take on these hard projects that he
feels that you know what the greatest
person is the person that is not afraid
to lose and dares to be great he just
told you that he challenged his self or
something that he didn't think that he
can win it yeah facts and most people
that don't believe unless because I'm
the first one King like y'all know me
I've settled IOP you know I many times I
shout he bounces I let he let me try
beat Sabre I had a good time with it
you never say but at the end of the day
I've never been I've been the biggest
skeptic Olivia you know ken you've been
a proponent right addict he said you
still got the good tea right saw how do
you feel I never I never got soft I fell
on VR picked up the question did he got
it right he just got it I realized that
I was trying to do for me picking up the
quest was about half-life Alex period so
but I didn't realize that most I have
paid for a singular game that was
definitely that was definitely uh of
what you would call it a moment where
your heart
oh yeah when they do when it didn't work
initially oh so yes I was able to
sideload it because like I said last
week I don't have a tower PC at the
moment I just have my laptop but that
sounds pretty powerful so I figured it
was cool what I realized is the power
consumption you need something that it's
able to hold more juice so it the oculus
link at least at this point wasn't
working right so I had to sideload it
with them with virtual desktop and then
do it that way you just have to make
sure you have a very fast in-house a
Wi-Fi connection because it's coming
directly to there so once I was able to
do that no I'm gonna tell you right now
half I've Alex it it takes half life
half life for me especially half life 2
especially with the advent of physics
and the gravity gun it made you feel
like you can control so many aspects of
that world in a way where you know how I
like to talk about the the immersive sim
and how it allows you to sort of break
the game mm-hmm
half-life Alex sort of allows you to do
that like it allows you look okay now
now you can literally manipulate
everything in the game and to create
scenarios that in a normal situation
even in a normal game you probably
wouldn't think of doing like whether
it's just like physically ducking down
or grabbing something and throwing it in
any direction things like that that have
been already been done in VR mm-hmm
half-life Alex takes the fidelity of
another the fidelity and the actual be
the sensitivity of the control and takes
it up to a level to never really see
just just out of curiosity I know you
know there's a lot of experiences on the
PIA PlayStation VR etc do you think that
this is like that prying thing it's like
you know this is why you want to be all
right is that is it the killer apps off
oh yes I I think I think it's definitely
part of the
I think that the killer app so cats off
the valve right yeah their steam gives
them the freedom to do experimentation
and and efforts on in industries that
other people just don't have the risk
appetite for and and so I think that
half-life Alex will be one of those
stepping stones to I think there's a
couple different things that have
happened just very recent I think the
quest you know give Facebook their
credit yeah getting an untethered VR
headset unbelievable
than anything else and yes I'll still
connect it to do the link so that I can
use some of the the rift stuff for VR
but maybe the consumers decision not
yeah right and I still have and in fact
if I had the choice between getting it
on the quest version or the rift version
or the steamvr version
I'll get the quest version every time no
there's a game like Gorn that the quest
can't run Frank I'll just buy it and do
the link do you say so so I think that
there's one milestone right like I said
you've got to be able to get it off the
cable and not tied to a PC
I think valve is showing you that given
the freedom game creators can create
experiences that will blow your mind
when you actually get experience we are
and this is the part that's the hardest
part for any of these kind of projects X
cloud was the exact same way nobody
believed it was real until they played
it hmm and so you get to a point where
you have to go look just try to try one
of the things that we did to the kids at
disneyland last year mm-hmm you know I
was still open and they have a second
party cathuria party company in the mall
area which is called the void and they
do VR experiences where you wear a full
backpack with the headsets and then they
have set up just sort of in a warehouse
this like you get told you actually get
to walk around right mm-hmm
and they had a Star Wars one so it's me
my daughter my son and my wife and the
four of us you put these headsets on and
then we're infiltrating an empire
structure on on a moon to define these
plans Wow and you put the headset on and
we start walking through we get into an
elevator and it's me and my family all
dressed
troopers my son's a storm troopers
anyways and they actually hand you guns
mm-hmm
you like you walk into a room where the
blasters are and you take them off the
wall
and you're holding one in real life mmm
but it's just some sort of prop think I
don't know what it looks like
yes it looks like a blaster yeah and
I'll never forget the floor buster in
this room and we have to break into the
prison and so there's this code you have
to enter on the on the screen and my
sudden I work on the coab and wife goes
do these work and she fires the blaster
and this is right after the droid told
you to be quiet so nothing the alarms
and it fires and it goes bouncing around
the room and then all the alarms go off
troopers are running at us and we're
trying to fight back and it was even to
the point where when you'd walk by the
lava when the ground was soft because it
was starting to Mel them the metals are
in the milk and you can feel heat Wow
like our family was blown away by this
experience and that's where you you see
sort of the potential of where it wants
to go lutely you know what would be
successful I hope so
yes I've had some successes there's also
on the windows mobile team
Brooke well I'm shut out Mass I'm not
gonna say your full-name 1977 it's the
Lord's Day - I'm super chats up Lords
new sub from mr. boo so be safe book of
X I got to throw the crest up for you
for that boomstick Excel do we miss
anything I think I've seen mass and s
okay so we caught up oh no one literally
just oh yeah of course
oh the Lord Jameson $5 super Chad don't
a crest stop for Lord Jameson did any of
you try spheres the VR experience
produced by Darren Aronofsky
I have not as anybody tried it sound
like a family member I like but uh so
that question and then I move on on I
wanted to say like again I love the
stuff did you say and I do agree with
you in a sense of you know these
immersive transformative experiences
right now again the skeptic give me
gotta push back a little bit did I say
so
what about
do you say to those who are like okay
you know you've got to buy this
expensive peripheral to to to actually
experience it and then you know as far
as the install base cuz you have things
like connecting I know Microsoft did
well would connect with the 360
initially and then I thought which was a
good idea was to pack in the Kinect in
the box or that more of the base like
for I guess my question overall is like
from a development standpoint how's that
pitch gonna go if not everyone has it
you know what I mean
and I think that you know do you feel
like like that those are some of the
challenges you guys face yeah I mean I
think that's that is the fundamental
problem this is why I think valve this
is why I call them out specifically yeah
they have the flexibility in the freedom
to experiment where nobody if nobody
buys a device there's no there's a ton
of risk in building an experience for a
niche product that may or may not take
off so you know at the same time in
order to mass produce a product that
everybody can buy don't work doing oh
don't don't get into Kings statue budget
like you need to you have to have
experiences that people want and that's
been sort of the video game console
experience for a long time I think that
at the same time Windows is chose a
model for how you can expand that
environment right and everybody runs
Windows in part early on and then the
start of Microsoft's life right because
everybody ran software whether it was
Excel or Word Perfect that they had to
have the Windows platform for right once
they had the Windows platform for that
purpose you could expand it out I do
think windows mix reality devices are an
example of true I've an avenue we could
pursue we're used to listen you already
have a Windows Device you already have a
gaming store with it yeah the the
Microsoft Store or its team now get
customers as you drive the price down
and you improve the quality and the
fidelity at least are you talking to a
guy who had an Apple Newton right like
some good early on but most people wait
for it to become a commodity smartphones
or commodity but gear VR didn't really
take off yet yeah that's why score at
the cusp but we haven't crossed the
threshold
yeah mm-hmm and it'll be some time
before you get to a price point and you
get to a set of devices that anybody can
just pick up and play in the and the
outlay right like yes I'm looking it up
upgrading a PC index itself as $1,000 I
do get a more expensive game right but
if you have my fan and you have the
means to do so your incentive to do it
that does grow the market even if it's
only incremental that's the point and it
drives people going well I'm not gonna
get the index just like you heard right
but I'll get the cost I'll get the link
cable about $400 my piece my laptop can
already run the experience or maybe you
can't but then the next time I get a PC
I mean you think graphics card sales in
the PC not a good point
technology you have to take a long-term
horizon approach to how these these
things will evolve right your aquadecks
cloud it runs on four g5 means you'll be
better there are still places there
upgrading to 4G markets come together at
the same time mm-hmm but you can't wait
for the critical mass to be there or
you'll miss that mark yeah absolutely at
that you have to struggle no it's a good
point like you said combination or like
I said price so to gate okay okay it
turns into if you build it they will
come you know and there's some there is
some of that that's been part of the
argument with X cloud there has been the
hey why would we spend because it's
opportunity cost right right we have
engineers working on this project this
project in this project are they all
going to contribute to the overall
health of business right you know in the
case of the console market look the
console market is relatively stagnant
not in a bad way but every time a new
console comes out there's a segment
percentage of gamers we want to buy a
console right that percentage is it's
pretty consistent across generations on
the total population goes bigger so
right it changes but like what we're
looking at with X pod is okay can we
break into a market but is it gonna
matter console long term
well well start with you won't start
with those customers right by any means
what are we gonna start with we're gonna
start with existing customers who know
this product and love this product and
just want more access to facts so there
were time what you hope hope for is that
somebody else goes oh I'll play Halo
with you I'll play doesn't need
you but I don't want to pay $5 for
console here we go at that point and now
you've brought another gamer in who
would never bought a console who never
will black yeah right exactly they're
like we shouldn't dictate to people the
only way you can experience this type of
game or this artform is if you follow
this process right my thing is all right
so in saying that right now it's been
notorious that on Microsoft wasn't able
to break into the Asian markets right
and now what we've seen is oh that X
cloud because they use their phones is
being used more in these overseas
markets that were hard to penetrate
right with for Microsoft I guess right
um like the SK Telecom deal yeah I see
the Korean yes um so in seeing that
happen was that the aha moment for you
guys was that the this is what I'm
talking about to penetrate that market
without hardware but with software was
it was that the absolute goal behind the
team III think that you can
it was absolutely intentional right now
we find and test different markets in
different ways like are we all have I
have a hypothesis that says this market
is a strong console market we will do
well in this for that reason in these
areas or this market is not a strong
console market but it's a strong gaming
market we should experiment on can we
drive utilization up by going in with a
different form factor or the lower
barrier to entry for those customers
because in some cases it's - it's not
just the access to the game the content
itself doesn't play well right right
good I think that's the biggest reason
you see the switch doing so well because
it you know it's more friendly in
countries now if you don't if you don't
like a console it's it's considered
ahead if you don't like a handout it's
considered a console so it like works
Everywhere's yeah and the content is
content that people care about we have
we have two switches by the way we have
a switch switch switch animal crossing
by my kids do emoji bills switch company
hi just like I said I'm glad you said
what you said as far big trailblazers in
the market you know still still trying
to take on that challenge and I'm saying
and you made some great points about the
price coming down those killer wraps and
then you know getting people to come and
I do agree with you with the untethered
experience if there's any way you know
guys can lock that down personally I
love a are I thought that was a really
cool way me so I'm super excited you
notice a to see your new role to see
what you go with it you don't say you've
always done these type of challenging
kind of things and I maybe we go see but
we don't rush fingers crossed man but we
gonna move on to the next part and on
kind of again the main event what you
were previously known for right again
what you mentioned which is the I
project that clap right letting you set
a lot about it so as of right now we
know you've moved on but with the team
how are you feeling about the state of X
cloud right now especially not the
series X has been announced and we're
seeing that technical you know progress
and how beefy it is you know in
reference to that so where do you feel x
cloud is right now
I think exercise is in a great place you
know that that bled into my decision is
to is now the time to make a move
because I think that the initial hurdle
there really that when you start a
project like this there's two sets of
hurdles that you have to get through one
you have to get the company to buy into
this is part of their future this is
part of their direction and in fact this
is you know one of the things I'm I'm
proud of not taking credit for it but I
I'm glad to see where it's come is that
when I was first started in Xbox right
like the notion the console business was
printing wrote it was understood every
time you came over the new generation
you'd come back with the new set of
games ball
was a various and now the you talking
about
one the series X is compatible with the
last generation all generations of Xbox
games compatible with previous
generations of hardware and then on top
of that X cloud is a first-class citizen
in the division in terms of expansion
like those two things it really is the
division sort of pivoting around this
notion of we just want everybody to be
able to play games right mm-hm and I
love that that's now the philosophy
which was not always the case
you know actually even before the China
launched I don't we talked about this
ever before I was at one of the
accessibility I owned accessibility for
the platform and at the time I remember
no these people are still around so I
think it's okay to say this remember we
talked about having to make the console
more accessible yes yeah cuz it wasn't
and I had a person in the room was like
relatively senior at the time saying why
would we ever do that
those kinds of people don't play our
games and now to see that attitude turn
into we've got an accessibility
controller that the industry recognized
one of the best ways to expand gaming
like I love that maturity and growth in
just a few years know not to cut you
that the cut I'm glad you said that one
of my most proudest interviews at e3 and
I want to shout out myself and I'm Sam
Tolbert who's with me was our Solomon
Romney and I believe he definitely had a
huge point in the design of the Xbox
adaptive controller and at the time I
thought this was genius I also want to
shout out the guys at coalition gears 5
they made tremendous excellent
accessibility options in the game and
it's so cool to see because like you
said you know some people get so caught
up in their bubble like why does you
know we need this but it's not about you
it so it's a whole subset of people who
would never normally get a chance to
experience these type of games and now
just making it easy for them and giving
them a point of entry and it can use
right like that is so cool so I
definitely have to salute you know I'm
saying those guys in you guys whatever
you even be in on that team which I
didn't know that that's pretty awesome
yeah I am I'm consistently amazed by
this by some players who feel that the
desire to restrict access to content is
the way to go I just it's it's we always
say the show and Lords it's like
antiquated thinking almost ah you know
it's just I think we're ready to
transition period and so people are so
used to the old way of things and it's
it's a shock for some so it's it's a
wake-up call that these games are going
other places that you know it's opening
up to other people it's so funny you
said that it's been a big big lately it
doesn't make any sense if I like to eat
my ice cream on the patio and you like
to eat your ice cream in the room it
doesn't matter where you eat ice cream
just eat ice cream man shout the bad big
games he said thank you for that bill he
said his sister-in-law has a physical
disability and that controller is
something I'll be picking up for her
birthday so thank you yeah that's
awesome man we really do man Oh speedy
Smith myself I see you so um yeah bad so
again you see excited about that now
about the series at the Tower of Power
like how excited are you you know I'm
saying about that device about what what
I am super like at a core just as the
next generation console like they hit
out of the park whoa you know I I got to
sit and I can remember sitting years a
few years ago watching them as we were
designing silicon and how we're gonna
make it work to see what it's turned
into you and the end product those that
is just an it's it's an awesome thing to
have been a part of I I admit that I'm
super excited about my new job but I'm
also having that moment of like I won't
be there for the people don't realize
how many years we've been working on you
know this kind of this next-generation
system isn't we put together last month
you know but there's there's years of
design and planning and everything and
and this was the the first time I got to
be a part of it from start to finish
right
Wow I joined the team prior to the Xbox
one launch but I was in the store so
most of my work was around description
services how gold how EA access would
work on the new platform yes right after
we shipped the one I moved over to the
platform team and that's what I got to
work on the One X and the one asked and
those kinds of things mostly from the
compatibility standpoint yes the
technology or the tools and processes we
used to test 360 games we now uses a Y
in a widespread way to test all games
and compatibility for all future
platforms which is great right so that's
how we know that first the Xbox one X
and now the series X will play the past
generations of games but the the series
X was the first one where when we had a
notion that we wanted to go to another
console what will it look like what will
be the killer features what will be the
things that we want this this platform
to do to justify people investing in a
new platform and I that is huge and we
would definitely I want to touch that as
well later on but yeah by me it's it's
so many components of it you know I'm
saying and I just love what's going on
check out the poll question later we'll
talk about that too but on another thing
that King mentioned I want to get into
or we move on from from X cloud you know
series X was that like King said man you
know we were sitting there trying to
debate what devices we were getting we
both do for phone upgrades we look at
that man but he was so excited about 5g
and um you know one of the decisions
obviously we're going with the the
Samsung ultra was at the s20 was because
of that and in combination with that
partnership that we see Microsoft so you
know they basically look they go to
share a vision they talk about you know
Samsung mentioned there 5g portfolio
Microsoft rich history and gaming so on
you know and we also talked about the
isp aspect you know what that's kind of
SK Telecom I believe t-mobile here in
the state so if there's a lot going on
you know I'm saying in reference to that
so like how do you feel how important is
5g
for project X class
I think this is where you you you look
at technology and when do things pivot
from a select product to a mass-market
products and I believe that this service
will optimize and and will work over 4G
yes quite well oh it does at the same
time well yeah right but the same time
you know 3G to 4G was largely driven by
people wanted to consume video on their
devices like that was ultimately what
it's about bandwidth it was about
throughput and that was the killer app
that got people to say okay it's time
for me to ditch my flip phone and get to
something that can actually do do the
video that I want to watch and that
helped drive the whole industry because
the thing you have to consider in the
telecom space is that these guys invest
billions of dollars in network
infrastructure design and planning and
new technologies that they then roll out
and have to find a reason to get their
money back
4G was video there's not a lot of
service you can't make video better in
for and 5g right because you already
have the bandwidth throughput to do I
guess I could get for 4k on my screen or
8k on my screen and my eyes couldn't
tell is the pixel densities so high on
those devices already right you look
good at 720p so all you're really doing
is filling a bigger pipe because you can
right so what are the services that
you're looking at as an industry player
when you're rolling out these 5g
services well I think the two big ones
that everyone's looking at are in-car
telematics and the things associated
with you know self-driving auto drive as
well as gaming yeah and I am hopeful
that it will be that the the first wave
of people will get into the service at
the 4G level but then as it goes to 5g
and that becomes ubiquitous kind of
thing for new phones that will
accelerate what you can see with with
the adoption of gaming round the go no I
completely agree and also what is it
such as far as the I love the
integration with ISPs I think that's a
great move you know to get more of the
masses familiar with projects cloud and
another thing I'm just gonna call it how
I see it man I think God gave a major
death blow to the competition you know
I'm gonna talk about
when God not I launch X cloud not only
was the tech and functional right but
then you have this immense library of
games the Tekken 7 it was almost like a
sweet you know of these games on the
goal that you have you know and most
likely I don't feel is kind of into the
deluded that most likely that's cause
gonna be packaged with ultimate or some
form it makes sense he said and you know
kind of sense but I think that was a
huge blow as far as the stadia as far as
their lineup and then I think the next
step and I want to shout out the verge
so I'm warning those guys they said you
got the guys are pivoting your former
team is pivoting now to PC and that to
me is also awesome because again that's
another section where they kind of live
at the competition and I think if you
guys can do that in conjunction with you
know the huge library also TVs you talk
ISP now you're talking all these
different devices and ways to access X
cloud and um I just want to know like
what do you what do you think about that
as far as the future as far as growing X
cloud that way well I think that you
know we've been public about this I've
said it in a couple interviews like you
know my my aspiration for this program
is that it becomes you can just game on
anywhere you have a glass screen in
front I'd love to get to that world now
there's a ton of hurdles both technical
illegal that will have to over overcome
but III think that everybody who's
looking at game streaming whether it's
fast or video or Google all acknowledge
that if you're just switching form
factors to a single device type you're
not really drawing it out broadly so you
start with where you have areas of
capability where you have gate areas of
expertise and where you can expand
beyond what you already have like we
have a great solution for already for
you if you want to game on your TV it's
called the console a smart TV clients
first yes when you already have that
experience for that kind of customer yes
but we don't have a mobile device then
you can play games on our catalog of
games right
Google's coming from a different place
right they have chrome they have it
installed on everybody's PC and they can
use that
way to lever up I think the entire set
of us though ultimately share that same
goal that same objective which is if I
got a screen in front of me I should go
play a game on facts I agree I agree my
question is this right because from the
outside looking in it seems like
Microsoft felt they didn't want to be
first they wanted to get it right and
it's in it seems that it was a rush to
market because it's still in beta and I
think that marketing of it saying you
know listen we're still in beta we're
working out the kinks and we're trying
to make sure that Android get it we're
trying to make sure that Apple gets it
we're trying to make sure that PC gets
it and when we get it right and we're
comfortable where we are with it then we
will get it out of beta form and release
it to the public and and also finding
out how they're going to price it or
where they're going to place it and does
that ease a lot of tension where it's
not a hard deadline like you have to
meet this to get to this because we got
to release hair because I think stay
Diaz jumped to release as saying a
finished product where you know some of
the Masters got it and didn't feel that
it was a finished product and they felt
that X cloud was in a better finished
state but they still claim beta does
that did that ease a lot of like
tensions around the work office where
that was like it seemed on outside
looking in like it was like less
pressure not you know per se like I'm
saying like not a hard deadline to meet
like you know like a crunch yeah I think
that well one you know this team the
start of this team was out of the back
impact team and you know more of us that
moved over to go run this and launch
this product and we all had the attitude
of with the back of our program that the
games will come out when they were ready
or not when they will do that does
actually create its own set of pressures
you know it's it may the force coming up
or the Star Wars games ready yet no like
we'll get to work on him right there are
certainly always pressure right but the
one of the things I've appreciated were
with Phil at the helm is that generally
the focus has been release a quality
product once ready and yes there are
always pressures and and I would not say
that stadia launching as a full product
and charging doesn't it takes the
pressure off us because we're only in
beta right now there's pressure on us to
get the market to so absolute like it
does work in both directions right but
it was pressure that's so a quality
product salute that salute the addy
breaking stuff too you know we can't
rush a product either because you you
you risk damaging in our case
specifically we have a brand that we're
tied to with X Xbox that is a brand
built on a reputation that they've
earned over decades now we can't really
undercut that and put us in a position
where we throw out some service that's
not ready for primetime so I do
appreciate the team taking having the
mental fortitude to go yep Google's out
and they're live and we're not gonna be
first yeah but we're not gonna release
until we're ready until we have a
quality product now be cool to have a
quality product ready to lease and be
first but you know if of the two being
first isn't always the most important
piece I agree okay so diesel do you
think that by Google coming out first
and sort of being limiting in its scope
in terms of where you know where you can
play right now and and and how you're
able to access them as opposed to you
guys where as opposed to X cloud where
it's just it's a it's an option do you
think they've kind of damaged the
narrative around there a little bit
being that they were first and that was
people's first big sort of eyes on I
guess I would say I don't think so cuz I
you know I don't want to speak to the
competition right I think their text
like they are a legitimate competitor in
this space mm-hm and you can't count
them out
we've made mistakes others have made
mistakes like I I don't think they've
done lasting damage of any type to this
overall momentum in the industry to
expand gaming to larger audiences so so
I still believe that you know I'll use
the VR space as an example they've been
lots of attempts at consumer grade VR
and then they don't really go anywhere
and now valve shows up with Alex and
people can't wait to play it so do you
think that you'll still get the right
experience at some point um and and I
don't believe that Google is just gonna
go oh whoa I missed that launch where
they'll continue to refine it and and
yeah but maybe I don't agree with the
business proposals they put in place but
they have customers today and more
importantly business policies are
probably the easiest thing to change if
your text legitimate yeah that's a good
point
but I will say again I got to talk about
oh oh that you know the way you guys
have handled it you know it has been
again that that that slow methodical
until it's ready like you said like when
kind of what Phil is reiterated but also
you know people forget the people are
impressed with the tech now and you got
to continually improved it but people
forget those already know Xbox 1s surfer
blades right so now you know we got the
the series X you know announced and shot
to digital foundry at this great you
know breakdown and they said one of the
more top moments was just listening and
seeing that the series X processor is
kind of capable of running for Xbox 1s
game silence SS x simultaneously so that
was cool in this whole new encoder and
how it really can affect X Cloud Servers
like can you talk about like how more
impressive it could potentially be with
those server go series X server blades
like so so here's what I can say you
know a lot of people when they when they
focus on gaming they're not spending the
time looking at other elements of the
industry serverless computing and the
growth in Azure in AWS as well as
Google's cloud like really is
demonstrated the ability you know you
can run ml jobs you can
a whole bunch of compute at a certain
scale and then nvidia and AMD come out
with new processors and suddenly the
capability that one competitor has is
leapfrog by the next purchase order that
the other person puts in place and so
there's there's absolutely just sort of
a I'll say a generic drive in cloud
compute that says we can consistently
upgrade the backend infrastructure and
start to drive economies of scale into
the way we distribute any individual
workload and so I do think that that
will have a huge impact on you know as
we improve silicon I'll just say it
generically speaking no silicon gets
better as is capable of computing and
doing more compute remotely as its
capable of delivering a higher graphic
fidelity remotely you'll just see a
natural improvement similar to the way
the back compact catalog looked better
on Xbox one X can you see improvements
in series acts like there's a natural
improvement and the nice thing about it
is because the hardware is remote you
don't have to keep buying new devices
you can just you your phone that you
bought you really spend a lot of money
on it will last you for a few years
because you'll continue to see
improvements on the back side take
advantage of what you can distribute
that's awesome he's nice
besides the latency improvements and a
graphical improvements by you know
improving the silicon what about things
that one thing that I like stadia has
specifically said about what this tech
can do like creating these these
humongous worlds or these these these
multiplayer experiences with like a
thousand players is that allistic or is
that is that realistic by improving
silicon or is it more just improving the
experience well I think it's you know
again back to the enterprise world right
like that is the de-facto way the
enterprise builds today and I don't
think that if you Google's talked about
it other people have talked about it
there's actually couple companies that
build game engines that are designed to
be effectively infinitely scalable and
you know this is long term this is far
out types of things but there's
absolutely nothing that allow that that
would prevent a game developer from
using the same sets of techniques to
improve exactly that dynamic right so
you can do scaling of the back-end
infrastructure so that when I have
20 people online I have this many
instances and when I have a thousand
people online in the same game structure
I have that many instances I can I can I
can upload a whole set of assets into a
cloud space that I can't ever do to a
device you know just as before the one
thing about game development when it's
when it's on a dedicated device is it's
always constrained by some technology
whether it's the drive or the graphics
card or the memory or the CPU there's
some device restriction that developers
work around this goes all the way back
to the Atari when you're when you're
music and sound effects we're just
static yeah processed through a sound
ship a certain way and so when you move
development to the cloud at the
enterprise level one of the advantages
that they have there is this sort of and
this is an enterprise discussion but
it's the dynamic pricing model of I can
pay for you compute when I need it and I
can stop paying for it when I don't that
also means that if you flip that to the
developer side I can build scalability
into my app that allows it to go to any
degree without having to worry about the
target device that it installs on
because that's just spinning of its the
simplest terms I'll just spin up another
instance or container
yeah and I'll just run it and then if I
need another one I'll spin another one
up and another one up now games today
aren't developed to take advantage of
that type of thing we've talked about it
we'll talked about it in the future
they're certainly the capability for
them to do so and as cloud gaming
becomes more widespread there's an
economic incentive for a developer to
build experience you know that fits that
world and then once one somebody does
like the the gaming world is and I say
this with nothing but love is a game of
copycats right so it's a networked
networked multiplayer gaming comes out
in one game and takes over everybody
gets into it so people start doing Hort
one person has horde mode everybody and
you know half-life Alex B&V are
hopefully Spears that someone's gonna
develop a game for cloud that's a cloud
only game on someone's platform that
will take the world by storm and it'll
be another fortnight or whatever you
want to call it and everybody else will
then go okay that's the market I gotta
be there's no one it's gonna happen if I
knew what it was gonna happen who it was
there'd be another policy
pivot into the next topic real quick and
then um so pretty much you don't know
about like again tremendous history you
know I still feel that you have been on
the forefront you know I you know very
humble but I or the forefront of a lot
of technological successes you know to
game-changing moments particular
particularly you know that I've been
with you one obviously we talked about
what's the s cloud you know twenty three
twenty nineteen doing that whole thing
seeing how we were able to demo that
that that thing and you know it's in an
azure cloud server 400 miles away what
is it San Francisco you know sitting
this thing feels almost one-to-one
relationship you know went on halo I
mean again epic moments you know again
setting the trends innovation in the
industry and then obviously our first
meeting I want to pivot back which was
gonna listen
press up but for Lord James Lovell Oh
welcome to the realm brother you stepped
up the gold alright thank you for
hitting to join but yeah I appreciate
y'all around man really means a lot to
us so long yeah so again again there's
two game-changing moments you got to
either projects out and then he had
backward compatibility you know I call
it 399 getting at the payday and it was
so cool to see because again as we've
said before last hour you were here you
know at the time we were so used to
having the tech in of the older system
in the new system for it to happen but
then to virtualization and all this cool
stuff you know you guys made it happen
so and now you know we're seeing with um
you know the series X you know they
they're talking about halo 5 which
didn't even have HD are now having HDR
and you know all these cool 360 games
for 4k so you know let's talk about back
compat you know as far as how impressed
you were at that moment and then how
excited you are with series X kind of
bringing their library in yeah so I'll
I'll start with and right after this
before that III was the first like that
was a moment right I've been in
Microsoft almost 20 years and that still
is the highlight I think of my my whole
experience out there because if if
people don't know the very that was the
first time we had fan
we were gonna invite people into the
into the stands and actually decided to
have at the Galen Center the floor
filled with Xbox fans who had come to
the mall mm-hmm and gotten an early
access ticket yes and I had gone out to
the mall that Knives was with Larry with
Major Nelson and Aaron Greenberg we were
walking around and people were like oh
it's making Elsa know everything working
some other do's and what's funny is you
could say in fact we were talking about
because I was I was officially to 360
platform leader at the time and so we
started talking about 360 games and it
was like oh my favorite game was Red
Dead Redemption my favorite game was
Mass Effect and I'm just like yeah gotta
keep my mouth shut
and then we went to the you know we went
to the do the event and it got announced
and the best part of the announce was at
that setup we don't do them in this
facility anymore but there's giant
teleprompters hung behind the stands
that anybody in the stadium can see but
Phil's reading infirmities as he says
his Scrolls up you literally hear tens
of thousands of people gasp yeah
everybody got quiet for a second and
then he said it the whole place exploded
and even but even then right so so Mike
Ibarra came out and did the demo of Mass
Effect being played as sort of our first
thing and I've been working with Mike
then he had just become my new boss the
overall organizational boss for the
platform and so he and I worked on that
demo and got it all ready to go and then
he did it and even acknowledged to me
afterwards you know dinner he's like you
know I wasn't sure people were gonna
care and I just didn't know but I
trusted Phil a trusted you so we did it
and it went over really well what what
exactly happened like do it was that
like a key moment when cuz you know as
far as like platforming goes like first
for most generations you don't really
see people do backwards-compatibility a
whole lot so when you decided like what
I don't know if you're allowed to say
this like what year did that start
happening in yes what development
oh so the one thing I'll say about
Microsoft is we've got tech for stuff
that we'll try three or four times for
anybody even hears about it and I will
say it and I think Kevin la Chapelle
acknowledged this like his team had
actually made it run of this before and
then they got pushed on a different
project and so it wasn't like this was
something we cooked up on the spot like
the tools have existed for a long time
you know we showed a game to that same
point we showed a game stream of a 360
game at a company meeting I think like
eight years ago nine years ago that's
been reported etc so people like that
we're always working on this stuff in
the background and Kevin a small team of
engineers some really brilliant
engineers some of them we talked in the
interview Eric hi Qi Spencer Perot and
others who have been working on this
tack and my role in this program was
really take that I'll call it a science
experiment and turn into a real product
and so we put some structure on a said
list and feels really big on gaming and
gaming history he's really big on
preserving in this case digital
purchases and so work on this program so
you can make something real out of it it
exceeded our wildest expectations right
we figured we launched some games people
be think it was cool we'd then be able
to use that tech on key titles and you
start a release this stuff but it it
tops right like it became one of the
highlights of the show that year and he
has a game a big program and fortunately
we had put structure around it so that
we were able to quickly commercialize it
at a higher scale than we had planned I
think I've also shared this but I'll say
it again the ones that I do regret was
markings like well how should we
communicate in your games I was like
listen when the games are running will
tell you and you can tell us which ones
you want to release anyway okay great
so then they immediately went out and
they built the website that said both
for the games that you want so you know
but what it did do and this is where I
will you know
leadership is always sometimes it's the
intangibles that you see fills love of
gaming and his sir
you'll shift within the organization you
say look all games are important all
gamers are important and there's not
just the what's the latest and greatest
that you have out there you know even
for a game like a Call of Duty or a Halo
or any of these top titles the factual
population of gamers like a good title
hits twenty twenty-five thirty percent
but you don't see titles hit a hundred
percent of customers Realty
hmm at least not when they're initially
launched right and so it's realizing
that you've got these various
demographics who like different types of
experiences or that they want to
experience him that at different times
yes that was the big learning with
backing Pat right the the 360 was such a
huge library and was in existence for so
long people forget that Mass Effect game
there was a whole generation gamers
didn't even know what it was you even
told me when he said the story last I I
do have another question about it before
yeah because pay the bills real quick
shouting who did their for you hold on
hold on one second
because you know Bill's been dropping a
whole lot of phil jim's
yet people haven't been catching you
know in the but both right name and what
I do like what I'm hearing is you know
first my bet was right he is the right
man for the job
you know um when a team is led by
somebody that has a vision and and the
team buys into the vision of individual
you start to hear them talk about the
good qualities and of things and all
games matter you know no games left
behind those stuffs aren't just little
slogans they are in the company and it's
starting to become fiber of the company
and the level of this is from me outside
looking in I do not work for Microsoft
you know me looking in as a consumer
right um the level of brand loyalty that
y'all are building is growing it the
confidence is growing
see when you drop off the series x2
digital foundry and they just did a
latest video of this series of videos
but the latest video was actual he going
into each piece of the silicon gap and
how he put it together and how he felt
about it the level of confidence for
company to do VAX to are somebody that's
not beholden to uh you know to say great
things about them there's going to tell
it like it is that level of confidence
is outstanding Anna Anna Anna start from
the top down that level of confidence D
do you hear how builds confidence in
what he does this it's amazing to me to
hear this and into actually gives me
honest seen it you know I can't say a
lot of things but I've seen it in your
eyes when we was talking at fan fest and
you sly q Did you touch it yeah and I
did in Delilah was standing right there
Delilah caught the footage I mean it's
amazing you're doing truly amazing
things and it in in in the shows that
you guys care and I just had to say that
because you know you've been real quick
cuz I gotta give it added cuz I got a
question so I'm gonna put up the crest
again shady gamer two dollars which a
shout out to Bill for being a genius you
know salute you don't say and of course
my wife shut out the Smitty Smith Chris
Hart I know you ain't talking after the
beating I gave you last week
don't let me open the book of X what the
[ __ ] today already sparring already in
chat that's cool but let me get it back
to addict because I know we were on in
the back compact question and I also
want to transition to what he's gonna
say also in reference to the PS 5 as
well so get your
she didn't attic I know you was about to
jump off on that so I'm a couple
questions actually all right so the
first question when I ask is you know
obviously we're backwards compatibility
I would say recently here especially
we'll follow the announcements with you
know Xbox series X and the PlayStation 5
with their backwards compatibility I
think a lot of people have a lot of
misunderstanding to how that whole
process is now obviously you can't go
into everything because we'd be here all
day and I'd have a headache so yes what
I'd like for you to do is just like
briefly go over like the process to
bringing a game to backwards
compatibility so there's really I'll
defer some of this so a good friend of
mine and some I work with for a long
time Jason Monell took over the team for
me as I moved on so he's been running
the compatibility program now for the
last couple years and I think there's
really two levels of compatibility that
you have to look at there's the initial
round of compatibility that we did for
the Xbox one which was what the team
started up doing and that was building
an emulator that ran in this case
PowerPC code on an x86 architecture and
allowed us to bring the 360 games over
and run them effectively in a wrapper on
on the Xbox one system that's the kind
of compatibility that gets us to the 360
and in some cases the original Xbox
games into the system and into the Xbox
one catalog we also used I mentioned
before we've used the same set of
tooling and test processes to validate
that existing Xbox one games will play
on new hardware this started with the
Xbox one X mmm because some games are
temperamental I'll say they're the way
that their game engine runs just an
increase in the clock speed destabilizes
the blast and so we went through a whole
process by which we validated that when
we move to the more powerful console in
the Xbox one x from the original Xbox
all those games also ran and we're able
to use the same team the same test
processes to do that then also as part
of that initiative when you're looking
at titles that run you're also looking
at the existing Xbox emulated 360 titles
and making sure that they also run and
in that case you can also tweak the
emulator
to make it work better that
compatibility effort that we went
through then became a capstone that said
okay
going forward Christo came out and said
we're not gonna leave you behind
we're not gonna leave you beyond your
digital purchases we're gonna make sure
that we continue to maintain
compatibility and Jason and his team and
my team and initially all worked as part
of the next-gen planning to make sure
that compatibility was a core structure
of the heart even if the hardware design
so that's where you're starting to see
the second layer of that coming to play
now which is your games your peripherals
I'll move forward and we'll play lean is
just huge future-proofing huge that is
such a big deal and I'm so glad you
definitely said that because again it's
it's a huge section of gamers like I
said that sometimes they worry like you
know even parents right it's like you
know if I gotta buy this system oh I
bought all these you know console these
pretzels in these games for little Jimmy
now you're telling me I got to get a
whole new ticket so to bring all that
forward is huge adding I know you said
you got a second question and I had a
question like in terms of timeframe of
you know we've briefly you know a couple
weeks ago about necessarily like the
speed how you know you guys established
a good way of doing this and then you
know moving forward things get easier
and easier so like at the very beginning
was it a lot more difficult than it is
no you know I don't obviously you're not
currently over there anymore but I'm
sure you still got it a concept how they
do it now it's I assume it's drastically
easier than it was at the very beginning
um it's easier as a loaded term it's
definitely more efficient one of the
things that we were learned early on
we've talked about this Saul Shara when
we vary when we did the first announced
and it was running and it was running in
our preview program and we found a
pretty significant bug with the way the
scheduler worked and for those who don't
know the scheduler is what processes the
threads in a certain order and make sure
that they can be and and and the way the
scheduler works on the 360 is
fundamentally different than the way it
works on the one right and so we had
built into the emulator scheduler that
works a specific way and then we found
that the way we had built it may not
work for most of the games mm-hmm and so
we put one of the smartest guys I know I
still work with him today on this and he
and he rewrote the scheduler from
scratch and got over why like those
kinds of efforts those Herculean sort of
like well no one's going home till we
figure this out
kinds of things are are largely done
right we now have a system where it's
repeatable it's consistent and if we're
doing a change in supreme it's a pretty
specific change done for a specific
issue we don't have any kind of
wholesale well the underlying structure
doesn't work we better figure something
out kind of problems and so in that
regard has become much better but it's
been that way now for a long time some
of this is in a tech conversation some
of this is rigour in how you test things
it's really now duplicate things like I
tell people all the time when you're
doing graphical comparisons right right
games games do everything in their power
to make it impossible with that side by
side they they add randomness to the
world so that certain weather conditions
and time of way and all these things
factored in you're like well how am I
gonna get gameplay captures from the 360
version that matches the one version
into a side-by-side to make sure that
the frame rates stay the same to make
sure that the lighting and the depth
color depth is the proper color depth
we've built the backbone infrastructure
now that that stuff is something that
everyone knows how to go do it still
takes a long time sometimes so it's not
necessarily easy it's not like you push
a button and spits on reporters yep
they're good to go but but the process
is understood by everybody involved the
program that makes n' then that you just
join the room I urge you after podcast
is over go to to check out your perks
also go to the YouTube channels a lot of
videos that is locked out from the world
that you get a chance to see you get a
chance to see stuff with ghosts and me
for the first time meeting and stuff
like that and you also get a lot of
bloopers stuff like that video so go
check those out and those emoji snows
about yes eating a small yes
what's up in the chat you know those
little I'd also be given back to Alex
what ask so our Slee you know Atticus
something you mentioned and we know what
the competition is doing we you know for
the first time we're hearing you know
Sony it for us to be that's five you
don't mention back compat but they seem
that have some questioning in reference
to the messaging right and what's gonna
come forward and what's not gonna come
forward so like I know you can't because
I was you're not working they're gonna
say to what they're doing but you know
is there I don't you bet you keep
mentioning the challenges right so it's
as far as all these generation you know
Xbox you know software and being able to
have that compatibility and innocence
like this I want to say in a sense this
really in-depth QA by supposed to you
know everything else is going on so you
know
can you speak to like how difficult that
is and maybe someone maybe that baby why
are they having or the wording issues or
saying hey they're just gonna be able to
do a certain amount of games they can't
do ps3 or whatever is I know attic you
I've mentioned something like that you
guys spoke the bill and reference to
this correct in reference to UM PS five
back back back you know like you know
the challenges man isn't is it real with
these different generations of software
yeah I mean so here's what I will say oh
I wanna say two things about the
PlayStation 5 one like these challenges
are real and they're not you can't
trivialize one company's capabilities or
another what I one of the things I will
say is I think I strength that Microsoft
brings the table is at our core we are a
platform operating system company yes we
build we build hardware but we build
some great Hardware in the surface and
the hololens in the xbox but generally
speaking our bread-and-butter and what
we've been doing for the last 30 plus
years is building platforms and so you
know if you're developing today even if
you're building a game for a different
platform you're probably building it on
windows and so we have a core
understanding that i believe is a
strength that we can leverage we don't
always do it well but it's one that we
have and what i'll but i will say that
hardware varies so much and developers
especially the ones that get access in
gaming typically where they get access
to the metal do
just crazy things to optimize and make
their games the best experience possible
as I mentioned before based on the
limitations of the hardware platform
they have in front of them right and so
I can't speak to the technical
challenges that Sony has with the cell
design architecture other things they've
done but so they may have hurdles that
they can't you know Wilma gum or they've
made a decision that from a business
perspective it doesn't make sense and
that's their call to make not mine what
I will say and this is maybe just know
like I watch these presentation about
the PlayStation 5 I loved it here's the
thing break it down that man is
brilliant and I and I feel bad because I
feel like his marketing department put
him in about something that someone like
nothing when I say is gonna tune into
that developers are gonna tune in that
and we're gonna learn a ton of stuff in
the motor who's a genius right
and sorry to mark Cerny did not stutter
one time I was in a bag oh he didn't
even have that you know that that time
frame where your minds catching up to
what you want to say you have none of
that
he went from and like you try doing that
I encourage everyone in the chat to try
talking for 40 minutes
oh yeah straight on during her
innovative absolutely and like you said
bill to you you know sit like you're in
pocket you you you are there with this
genius talking it's like you said it
perfectly and I've said this before to
other gamers
there's no disrespect right it's just
it's just that I personally felt the
same way you did which I felt marketing
did him no favors shout out to the cops
go about but that that's what for but
continue on in your impression of it
well that's where I say like he released
a lot of good technical information
about their console that will and and
what platform holders ultimately try to
do I think will do it well and I think
they'll be successful at it too is give
developers a set of tools that they can
take to use to deliver on a vision that
they've got for some type of game right
and whether it's we've got more
teraflops and they did where they got a
faster
be than we knew like we're just giving
tools out we're building a platform then
other people will take and they will
build experiences that and including our
own in-house studios right that will
take advantage of those capabilities to
give you the gamer and experience you
wouldn't get in any other way and and
it's it's tough to judge right the
capabilities of another organization I I
will simply say I don't think there's
any we're not smarter than anybody else
right we just have different priorities
and different investments right that we
think is important for the product we're
releasing right and they may or may not
align with Sony's right but that's not
because they'd lack the ability or it's
too tough a problem for them to solve
and not us right out of this case at all
I think he's an example of they have
great thoughtful intellectual
engineering leadership and he did and he
and I thought he showed it in that
presentation I even liked Mystery
Science Theater 3000 said you know these
times that we're living in at this
moment right now that was definitely
necessary for what they were doing and I
do appreciate the fact that they tried
to work around it and they try to bring
a level of you know take a type of
conference type with the feel to it um
what I would say is this what I heard
from before cuz I'm not an IT guy
alright and and you know listening to
you two guys talk about this stuff is
like head spinning but um I will say
this you explained that changing clock
speed and things can destabilize certain
things and what I did notice that in
this series X it is a very stable exact
box and what I've noticed is the numbers
aren't variable you get this you get
this and is that is that because of the
the house that you've built before you
had to bring that house over in a
certain fashion to make sure that okay
we want this to to be the power level
and in the exact level where we need to
be this is the ceiling where we're
looking at this is what we're trying to
achieve
alright let's let's get to this but we
need it to be stable in a fashion that
the old stuff can rely on it being
stable you building a great foundation
can you say anything to that is that is
that my perception of it is am i on
point or am i a little bit off
I would think I'll just say it this way
I think that we had very specific the
Xbox one launch wasn't the best launch
and so we had very specific learnings
from that that we didn't want to repeat
I think that what you're starting to see
is an organization that's gotten smarter
and more mature about what it means to
release product in this era with the way
the world has changed over the last so
many years and we had it we had a
concrete vision like we we don't go into
this necessarily worrying about what
others are gonna do you go into
something like this making sure you can
do the best that you're capable of and
then the outcome is whatever the outcome
is facts and you either miss I think
it's just like a life lesson right like
you either meet the bar you've set it
and that bar is good enough for
everybody else or you know you're you're
the best semi-pro play there's no other
way to describe it then the best you can
I love the Xbox team that's there today
I think we're a fantastic group of
engineers and I've enjoyed working with
them and and this and you what you're
seeing all what I will say is what
you're seeing is the outcome is a bunch
of dedicated people working really
really hard for a long time to do things
the right way they understand yeah I'll
just jump in right quick you know you
know first off wit like you said we all
know about the Xbox one launch right
week I completely agree we don't we
don't feel it was necessarily the best
representation as far as a launch but to
see Marcus off in the position where the
aggressiveness the the transparency
right I think that to me speaks volume
is saying that confidence in the product
when you like look digital foundry you
guys you know I'm saying Austin Evans
you got these are guys that's going to
pick a partner tech and I'm saying these
are guys who are going to get down to
the metal who are going to say what you
can and what you can't do
so if you're showing it to these guys
you bet
be prepared if there's any issues you
know say it will be brought up so to me
that's a change that that's a philosophy
trade that is confidence we start to
seat with the Xbox one X and it's now
come the same type of marketing and I
have to give praise to that because you
know this is something I've wanted to
see for Microsoft and again not to
backtrack back to just or like say
something negative about Sony all the
time but I have to admit that was my
frustration with the marks or anything
as far as you know look I get it
theoretically he says stuff that
speaking to you Bill you're sitting
there he's he's spitting these bars and
you're like oh my god this is the
greatest thing ever right for us it's
like you have to give us real tangible
examples you have to give us benchmarks
to show this things that you're tall but
not saying that you're lying but just
that that's what Microsoft is doing and
I feel that you guys are doing so well
right now it's like hey you want to see
four games and the resume feature here's
the implementation right you you want to
see all these different things here's an
example of Gears five right now
comparison with a twenty eighty you
don't say an HD are some great racing we
got a Minecraft demo right it the
difference it as far as mind share is
huge that is huge because you're getting
people to say okay you know what this is
a reason to get this box right here is a
reason and again I'm not saying Sony
will never do it right we just talk
about at this current point you guys are
knocking it out to park you know I'm
saying and that's the only I guess that
was the the frustration from the
non-technical folk when watching the
Sony presentation that's a la minute
well sure I think I understand where the
frustration comes from you know I will
say there's two sides to every
organization right we have we have had a
very strong marketing department
greenies fantastic right he is so
passionate about building brand and
building fan interest in everything that
we do and make sure the fans get heard
make sure that fans get seen Cyndi
Walker has done an amazing job in how we
do the reveals our stuff and even prior
to those people you know I'm still very
close with Albert Panello you know and
anime right there that's like what
Albert that's right like Albert dry
drove a certain level of just
accountability into the messaging that
ultimately that org is now as in sync
with an engineering or gazaís ever seen
hmm and we all have the same mission we
all the same goal and that's where you
start to see this this stuff come
together in a comprehensive story that's
doing well look I I fully expect that
Sony will eventually show gameplay and
people will be like dang that looks
amazing
mm-hmm and they will show a title that
people will be all excited about they're
gonna produce a good console I don't
have a doubt about it it's gonna be a
good experience so we're just at a
different phase of our messaging and we
have some people who really understand
their craft even though it's a
non-technical craft they still deliver
it it's just as much a craft right as
anything you do on the technical side
the engineering side and they're doing a
great job at it
no does that pay the bills right quickly
to move on please tell us what you had
to play a fanboys based their whole
generation on numbers but cannot compute
12 is a higher number than 9.2 it's a 3
oh my god whatever that was they choose
next week the book of Acts Luke oh the
book of X like that you gotta say X
Chris you cannot beat the good book keep
trying the book of Acts it's pretty
significant to that a future I'll be
done Chris make you doubt it you ate the
podcast it is a little you can't say it
like you know that that dark melody you
have to get the saint like the
[Laughter]
the creator of the book of X I just want
to know how do you like it moving on
last thing and then we get it to secrete
the question that we asked the RO um in
reference lasting what s cloud and I
want to forgot to ask you was on dynamic
latency input and I noticed you guys are
really stressing that that whole
limiting the barriers to getting those
you know that relations that control you
know I'm saying you know how do you feel
about that
and on also I think I think was digital
finally I mentioned and reference to
even stuff in the series X being able to
detect the TV that and switch it into
game mode then the new controller now
with what better latency features that
will be firmware upgradeable to the with
the old stuff can you not pay attention
I'm on it I'm on it but uh but I'd be
like how do you feel like all these
improvements is this really gonna take
this this X cloud to the next level what
I can say is that we've spent a lot of
time as much as bandwidth was the
determining factor in the quality of
video latency really is gonna be the
quality factor in the determination of
gameplay experiences when they're remote
it's been a core tenet of how we built
the system from the beginning one of the
things you know there's a couple
advantages I think that Microsoft does
have in this space one you need to
distributed cloud network there's only
like five companies in the entire planet
that have one big enough to do this kind
of stuff we're one of them that helps a
ton and those and those in like like the
concept of latency for gaming is not
just the gaming only concept right when
you talk about what I want to do with
low-cost devices and remote you know VR
na our experiences you still have to
have that same kind of the human brain
is very susceptible to latency in a VR
experience so if we don't want people
walk around with glasses on vomiting
that technology is is widespread in
terms of its value but gaming is one of
the things that pushes it forward I
believe that the getting to work with
Microsoft Research getting to work on
this technology and this team I'm gonna
made dr. bill nail awesome and this is
very encouraging man I am super pumped
you have no idea but I hear this type of
tacit again you making the unbelievable
believable you and your team you know
saying it is really you know I cannot
wait to see the next-gen also with you
we're just Microsoft in general and you
and that VR space to make me believe you
can make me a believer I'm right because
I've been a skeptic you know so I gotta
ask you to forget there we'll get there
I hope we do that so I got to ask the
questions that we ask all the guests in
the realm that lower bill last time you
were here we had since debut top five
game of all time
you had missed that because it didn't
exist now that you are back almost 100
episodes later
what is Lord Bill Stilwell's top five
video game franchises of all time okay
Jesus put me on the spot so okay so we
start with any time 94 and for those
foolish people who don't find me on
Twitter like I'm mostly gonna tweet
about just so we're clear
so NHL 94 for sure
I'll say road rash for the 3do because I
definitely want to make sure that that
gets put in there I'll have to say sieve
just the Civilization series all up
because that was definitely just the
mainstay especially for the PC and then
you're gonna put me on the spot so I'm
gonna pick an Xbox game just because I
have to pick it up and for me it's it's
Gears of War like that Oh like as much
as halos our franchise Gears of War is
the one that speaks to me as a gamer
probably more that is by far my is it
the first one or is it just a series in
general I think it's the first in a
second okay the series in general I
think is I'm look I like all of them
even even four and five and judgment and
because I love what that series like the
underlying story of that series talk has
about family
yes and the extended family and that
what are the motivations behind it in in
tough times I'd like some of you know I
had probably one of the toughest years
this year and that's the the family's
important to me is everything for me and
so that's why that game more than
anything speaks to me and as much as
you'd expect me to say for my fifth
overwatch or destiny or some other game
honestly for a third-party franchise
it's Borderlands ii won that game the
number of hours I sunk in that game I
probably have sunk more hours into over
a while
what that's a surprise listen make sure
that y'all go to game pass right now
because that game is about to leave game
your past but make sure that you go to
game pass download those games and you
can actually play what bill just said
which was mind-blowing portal and going
to go do it and I'll probably change my
probably changed my v over time it
doesn't get caught on the spot but oh my
god look it's Lobo look at dizzy oh I
like this guy look at the portal and
credits don't encourage him slobo he
said it could change salute the boil is
well-designed series one of the you know
that the OG Luda shooters still going on
strong fantastic now yes dizzy The
Godfather of Lucia yes I understand
they're going crazy to chat so this is
hard now we may get you in trouble we
gotta ask you this is a gaming question
favorite console of all time and why
eighty generation we've expanded from
all the way to past and down yeah let's
go so you know it's gonna be one you
know to be one of two I already don't
know you know what I'm gonna go must I
love the 3do I'm going to go with I've
always had consoles an Atari what
beginning I think they eventually call
the Atari VCS and the 2600 the fifty
four hundred and seventy eight hundred
which is basically der yeah I've had a
lot of Commodores and Apple computers
but for me the first console game that
was actually the I'm now a console gamer
you know in phrase what was the genesis
up my mode you keep talking and more
importantly sighs Marine Corps and one
of the things that we used to do we sit
the squab a you had time to kill and we
put on Bulls versus Lakers or goals were
Blazers and/or we put on one of the NHL
games and we just sit around the squad
bay and kill time and you know like this
is before there was online play like
those community that tough that social
experience that's what makes games right
it's not just me playing somebody and
I'm playing bowls and he's playing
Blazers I'm playing as a Black Hawk to
Jeremy Roenick and play somebody else
and I lay them out in the game and the
stretcher to our cheerin and we're all
engaged and like that to me is what
gaming's about yes and and also that
game that system yes like it was always
intended was always intended was always
Nintendo and then say it came out was
just like let's go let's does okay the
big question what about Sega CD the
sacristan for your brother he said bill
is there anything you would like about
the Xbox series X more than any feature
and what are your predictions for the
future of consoles they try to sneak
some questions into Bell I don't know if
you any feature with the Xbox series X
that's your the most excited about you
know as much as people talk about and
this is just the next-gen in general if
it's both as much as people talk about
graphics and CPU etc I'm actually super
excited for this the increase in speed
or on storage you know it's ironic cuz
the first game we showed for bat compact
was Mass Effect which have the elevators
they're busily to get time to load the
levels yes and as much as I love destiny
used to jump around but then we can't
even eat anymore on PC like because it
goes straight just once
SSD is such a game changer like you know
what you see in the PC version of
destiny right like like I used to I got
used to load up the game go to the tower
and go get a sandwich yeah right you
play with an SSD on a PC and you're like
oh I don't have time to stand up before
it's already loaded up in the thing so I
so I
and that's just the mechanics of
existing games right now when developers
have that knowledge in front of them
that this is now no longer up all night
what can they do to sort of have that
seamless world that streams in all the
time and I think I think that will be no
pun intended game-changing for the
industry and might end up being the
killer feature for the next absolutely I
got one question for Bill before he
leaves because it just popped into my
head all right
being that you like to challenge
yourself to no end
um do you see yourself making a game so
it's always been a dream of mine so I
Manama give you the inside scoop about
my journey this last year I really
looked hard at moving to a game company
and I do want to build a game I do want
to be involved like I just it's
something that that's to me that's the
missing part of my portfolio
and and I've always been on the platform
side of the business one of the things
I've loved specifically about X cloud
but it started with the back of that
program is that a lot of my job is
working with developers and I spend a
lot of my time to explain the platform
features and how they can use them and
I'm always amazed and I sit in these
rooms you know like well we got this
concept for a game and so we want to do
this thing and how would you work with
your tech and these guys are
unbelievable and then the amount of
creativity in this industry that you're
trying to untap and open up on your
platform
I do want definitely want to be on the
other side but by the same token I'm not
cheap you know
I don't I want step back and not be able
to like take care of my family it could
be like a little passion project on the
side that you're working on it's a
timing thing for me right like between
oh no Meah I coach youth hockey and I
play youth I play adult hockey I also
volunteer for search and rescue
like those take up time so when I do
have a spare moment if I'm not spend
with the family I've usually got some
other commitment outside of both those
search and rescue and youth hockey are
both charities so that we're raising
money and my hours spent there health
fund those organizations and so I'm
sitting down writing a game is a dream
that probably won't happen I probably
catch up to you on statues but speaking
of which I just want to say as much as
you turned off your Black Panther I got
my Witcher let me tell you something
when bill and I got a chance to talk I
didn't know that you can also tell if
you're watching the stream who's done
this professionally by their backdrop
and then there's me I'm sort of like my
kids have taken over the office because
their schooling from home now yeah Ella
gay to a back room
thank you for just another game yeah I
still got one time but no bill I know if
we if you could had great I'll never
throw you out I got nothing to do my man
so he's hanging that's was so bad so we
get it to the pontine life
we got the question last week poll
results are in and to the question with
the tech spec reveals of both the Xbox
series X and the PlayStation 5 this past
week which tech features do you think
will be the most important the winner of
two devices let's try the device the
three-way i/o peephole as 64 percent is
the 12 teraflops dx12 ultimate and full
our DNA to pick up 100 of the series X
group coming in at second place at 27%
was the next gen SSD variable clocks and
3d audio group of PS 5 and coming in at
last place at 9% was I don't care until
we get that digital foundry side-by-side
comparison I'm upset at you guys but I
know we will not probably get ahead so
we will have to settle for number one
anytime I talk about these mess with my
memory get messy with the gaben go for
tape just wondering that attic leave for
work Wow I work one less day the week so
I don't have to leave early for making
the work sacrifice you know so we get
into one topic today become very hot o
be that we get to talk about just about
anything about so vs I'll have to
confide in each other well when they do
talk about switch they never shut up
I'm assuming I'm gonna pivot to you
because all this bravely default talk
because you didn't watch it did you play
I did not play it oh you okay good I was
referring to the previous ones that you
played I played the first one but that's
it the beta yet but I beat the first two
the bravery and bravery second mm-hmm so
let's set it up solve on one do you get
a chance to see the direct and I did you
did let's set it up you know what kind
of things excited you that cold kind of
bit for me it's what I've always said
about the switch from the moment the
switch got announced and I in and the
power they said was was comparable to
last generation if not a little bit
better yeah I said I want my entire last
gen catalog on this machine mm-hm
cuz last gen for me it was just like
there were so many games and I got most
of them I just never got around to
playing most of right so this is the
matter of how do i how am i able to play
this stuff when I'm never home right you
hire Bill's team and you allow them to
put it in a fashion that you don't have
to rebuy every last Gannett all over
again in the Nintendo fashion is he's
paying more again I have unique issues
I'm generally in a dungeon somewhere I
don't have great internet most of the
time I rocked out with X cloud when I
first got it to the beta and it was
grateful a little bit and then you know
again the nature of my job is that I'm
under a building somewhere most of the
time so then it just it's not it's not
viable on a day-to-day basis I hope at
some point that's not the case so I'm
stuck yes with Nintendo text that's what
I thought but you know for me like I
said it's it's continuing to do what I
what I always wanted to seem to do was
just to bring all these older games
forward
obviously games that are so stranded on
the on the WiiU stuff like that and in
bringing bringing forward games that you
know let's be frank most people are not
taking their way out to play or any ride
that so um I that that's what excited me
most obviously the new stuff they talk
more about the expansions to pokemon
sword and shield yes
bravely default to obviously uh the the
Marvel Ultimate Alliance additional in
the house to me right there I have to
purchase the game no we got you know let
me tell you something out too dizzy
dizzy I don't know if you store this I
don't know if you saw the trailer of God
I'm going to tell you this dizzy right
now this is the reason why I'm going to
purchase Marvel Alliance even though it
was like one of my best 360 games um you
know and I love the fact that you know
I'm able to still play it um I do say
this when I saw that trailer I woke up
because you know it was a lot of stuff
that I wasn't really concerned about
when I was watching the intended direct
it was well done when he got to that
game dizzy did he get your checkbook out
[Laughter]
he's got a beautiful article towards
game with that that top five takeaways
from the other two right yes
so yeah when he said doom must be God I
don't know who doom is you you guys are
love with danos to this point and Dallas
is a product of these organic he's like
50 cent mmm
you know he's organic he comes from the
underground you know it was Jim Stalin's
little creation and turned it to
something I was monstrous that became
MCU big bad
right but the greatest big bad was
always in my um marvel's staple he
always went up against the first family
first families the Fantastic Four you
know but doom permeated the whole Marvel
he has antagonized x-men he hasn't
agonized name or he hasn't agonized
Avengers oh he this he's single-handedly
this is how smart Doom is he
single-handedly the Silver Surfer
[Laughter]
[Music]
but yes you are right he is I won't say
that I think you you're all to something
in this I give me that in that I feel
famous was organic as far as they didn't
expect him to be I think they want to do
him to always be they're very bad but
Davis was the thing that kind of caught
fire and became popular you know I don't
know what what do you think but like a
reference to the Marvel Marvel Alliance
that kind of thing you know now you see
and I don't got a chance to see the doom
DLC that's coming for it you know what
did you feel about do them as a
character and also the game the ultimate
alive series well so Ultimate Alliance
is another reason to have a switch
that's actually the limit I wanted three
still bad that's why I get the second
switch you know it's it's interesting
watching the MCU build these movies out
with villains and the way they handle
what the movie versions of them need to
be like versus what do you do with a
Galactus what do you do with do what do
you do with you know I once they haven't
really shown well right skinless man and
others right there's a whole set of them
that because I think licensing
restrictions and Fox on this and other
things like that they haven't been
effective in pulling them in but it's an
untapped area where I think didn't go
forward the one thing I will say I tell
us anybody who asked you I'm marvel over
DC because I like hold on let's go I
like Marvel's heroes better because
Marvel's heroes are all say they're
humans that inherit some godlike
and the humanity's struggle to deal with
it that said I think DC villains are
spectacular whoa
so he's a civilian Oh si si si what what
what what he's explaining what is he
explaining is I've always said this DC
heroes are gods right and they're
unrelatable to the common man whereas
the common Marvel this is the genius of
Stanley I can't
state it enough is I think he saw his
self in all these characters or
something that he humanized them to the
point that you can see that they're
broken that they're flawed and they're
struggling but at the same time they
struggled to be a hero and we all want
to do good so when we read these books a
lot of times these books they do deep
into your core like it's something that
you can relate to like spider-man has a
job as a piece of delivery guy he's
working inside the Daily Bugle but at
the same time he's still trying to go
out and night to save and use his power
for good because his uncle died when he
used it selfishly which is a human trait
of a last you know you can relate to
that and this is that's what I try to
talk about like Superman is an alien
that came from space that is a god-like
you got here I mean Superman in my book
Superman is probably the most boring
comic book care thank you because he's
there's nothing you can do about it
right like you just except for his green
rock you nailed it with Peter Parker yes
likewise spider-man such an endearing
figure too especially to younger people
cuz he's a 16 year old boy
who's got all the problems of dating in
high school and working a job and then
he also at the same time he's given this
godlike power that he uses wrong and his
uncle dies and then he goes out and
fights carnage right like there's this
level that and it's I think what appeals
to me about Marvel is they have that
dichotomy in front and center which is
actually why I think Batman is probably
the most popular DC character because
he's the closest to the broken wall
it doesn't really have any skills right
mm-hmm just has lots of gadgets and he's
rich but but but then you look at the
villain I think the villains are the
exact opposite as well right
then Joker's just a broken guy yes and
you see what a Heath Ledger can do in
Phoenix communes with walking feelings
yeah yeah like what they can do with
those characters on the other side
humans who are broken but then also have
these powers I agree and that's the mix
that I think is you know when you have
the fan OSes or you have the Galactus or
you have doom it's harder for Marvel to
bring some of these characters and build
them as credible villains although hats
off to what they did with fan oohs yeah
yeah in the series today so you know
Dormammu like I think was a wasted
opportunity Strange movie yeah but that
character was so more powerful than they
could possibly portray him on the big
screen they lost something in the way
that they ended up using did you get a
chance to for a little bit I'll give it
to you back to Bill also well did you
get a chance to watch the direct or and
if not or anything and if you did like
anything that you caught from it that
excited it besides our model the other
thing I'll say is I mean I wish I was
engaged with the ring fit they sort of
feel like I want to try it but I don't
ever die don't really doc my switch ever
yeah I think I have to go find the doc I
don't know how much you should get out
of it it's very hard time looking for it
right now to you know saying what the
isolation thing and I want to shout out
one of our rises a lot which is like
$500 eric's he's got a good video up on
it and he gave it like the you know like
a hardcore fitness guy test is this
thing truly and he was right yes it
passed so you know Schlueter lord heck
they're more macho he's got an article
knows it game of that net about ring
ring fit I'm looking forward if anybody
knows where I could find it please I
want to pick it up this evening
$700
you know you're not no no listen
second-hand market right now with switch
products is insane my Wii U is going for
five hundred dollars and this is so low
bitrate Rigveda [ __ ] updating we'd
like to get your hands on
yeah I think just you know look we're
all going through this weird adjustment
to as we figure out a live in the house
and not in you know and do the right
thing and not leave we don't have to but
I'm going little bonkers so I need
something that I didn't watch it but I
went to one of those things that told me
the announcements yes I woke up to a
message from you saying XCOM God
announced models look I was like is that
a snake or is that like I don't know
what that I saw borderlands games like
that Amy but you know people want those
in a mobile fashion so if you want to
you're gonna have to deal with that
downgrade to those in 64 graph oh Ken
can you say this doe at it can you say
this far from any other machine that
they had other than a Super Nintendo
they have the support the third party to
a level I never thought I'd see
Borderlands on a machine I never started
I'll see the witch on the machine and I
don't care what form that they're
getting it they're getting him yeah did
you just get in these games this
goodness it's truly insane to watch
these two guys gotta come on this show
it's just not the Indy support right and
it's just it's the fact that they're
getting new stuff like if you if you
talk pound for pound brand-new stuff
exclusive to them to their platform
neither console could compare like not
the other big console can compare it
crazy the thing is it looks like none of
this stuff I care about I mean listen
like I said before I live in my own
little bubble and I'm selfish right on
apologizing to apologize I don't care
I'm not I don't care but I say this like
a lot of that stuff I did my kid don't
wanna got to the Marvel I was like oh
right so they did say something to me
it's about to go down flat but then
somebody else saw that Marvel on lines
is like it's not for me but they're
hitting see but then they the Yelp XCOM
to unions like me you know so they're
gonna do something they're looking like
they're gonna do something they pull you
in and these guys aren't stopping and I
just got to salute them because from the
shambles that was the we you to rise
like the Phoenix um it's only good for
gaming and I do appreciate them pretty
much is exclusive just on the switch and
it's just like you know people want
these games they're you know definitely
playing the the very downgraded version
on the Xbox at the end of the day if I
have the access to the better version
I'm not going to buy though you know I
have a sane if I at least a little
interest in I'll wait for stuff but
guess what we can that either
I literally don't care if you listen you
know I love switch for Nintendo products
if you wanna play ex-con to an amazing
game you'll love it well I've already
beat this game you right now he is boozy
addict yes well no it's not that it's
you give me a game and you know I mean
you've always said from the start of
ex-cons a great game on the switch but I
just played like a hundred and fifty
hours did I not just say that's cool
I bought it first party have I not
always thought you even that you rip
second party stuff this exclusive don't
you compare Final Fantasy 10 on the ps4
and Xbox to the switch it doesn't even
look like that's what they had to do to
get these on the platform cool yeah we
ain't go to here and be like oh it's on
it's awesome you guys oh yeah I love
that they got it on there like I don't
care and I hope I hope they do I hope
they do I hope they do do a streaming
service cuz when they did the Resident
Evil streaming you look great and I say
this because I've seen the future
I know I've touched the future pause um
you know when I was a fan fest and then
I got a chance to touch it when I got
home I didn't even know I was part of
the the
I checked it I was like I feel really
great about it
I want that level of fidelity to reach
the switch and I think through that tech
it can happen that way oh you know sold
because a lot of times you know like
addict said you won't be playing with
the worst version actually to be honest
with you if you can offload all that
horsepower and you're just streaming it
to to the system you can actually
achieve their fidelity without losing
what you're talking about like they
won't be the worst version it will just
be the version of it running on the tech
okay so get there
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait way back when no it's the one one
one of our monthly prizes right yes so
it just so happened when those rumors
are going around right so I text them to
fight you figure out how we do the
pricing whatever the case might be
so playfully playfully I'm when I heard
some rumors just totally playfully he
shut down completely I got no more
correspond comment on the speculation
boom and that was it I was it's like I
said when it comes to the switch I
bought a switch for Zelda I bought
Pokemon I I'm even considering Animal
Crossing I don't understand like
graduating on that I'm like what's going
on people like Animal Crossing it might
not be my cup of tea but I'm gonna at
least try it eventually
mario party about mario mario kart
whatever that mario maker game is like i
play their games i just don't play the
the porno because i have access to
better word you to the port I feel like
I said with Tzu we know where you're
coming from I'll jump in right quickly
and it looks I hear you I thought the
direct was fantastic um very strong a
lot of titles there's gonna still show
support animal crossing the dimensions
and we're gonna get deals see they're
gonna get content that games gonna do
numbers no it's already killing really
killing it UK and I think it's the
perfect game for the climate right now I
think that might be I think that might
sell everything this year yeah it's
looking monstrous right now so I think
it's gonna out so the Last of Us final
fantasy all that no no I think cyberpunk
is gonna punch it in the face I'll do
better knee with you this is one caveat
this is this is one caveat this is one
caveat and I'm a sadist in them and I'm
a hold true to this let's go
I do believe that that game launches
right separately without my caveat okay
but I believe when they're serious ex
launches that game comes to game pass
and that's when you getting smashed in
the mouth and bad steps dad stats listen
if this happens right if this happens I
will bend a knee on camera listen listen
are we talking listen listen listen
and he said animal Crossing's gonna be
the the highest selling game for the
year alright okay alright I'm down with
that again months ahead start my I'm
referring to okay obviously Call of
Duty's stuffs gonna beat it I'm putting
a cyberpunk against your gear joint
right against animal cross
and I'm saying this right because I
already know this billions of pre-orders
listen this is my caveat yes if that
game when they're Series X launches and
that game is in game pass this was on a
summer jam screen I'm telling you guys
if it launches in game pass when that no
no it don't hurt me you don't you don't
hurt me because you're gonna start
seeing engagement numbers okay it
doesn't it doesn't hurt me because once
somebody pleasing that we go by they're
gonna buy because I brought children of
mortar all right and I understand
purchasing will be the effect cuz
statistics has been shown that people
that try stuff in game pass wind up
purchasing this said go alright so there
is a higher percentage of these games
being purchased and I will bend my knee
on that so if it comes in game if it
comes in game past it has been engaged
brother let me know if cyberpunk is not
in game past so the caveat is game pass
okay
adding do you agree what bending me
bringing it bad it's our first for the
2020 do you agree on these terms
look enemy on camera Animal Crossing
loses the gear sales to arm what you
call cyberpunk are we doing this but but
he's arguing game pass and I'm arguing
cells so it's confusing is that it has
to be a game pass some point has to be
engaged so watch what out says which one
at the end of the year bill Stillwell is
with this cuz all I know is I've been
told we look at six seven million all
right
[Laughter]
question first party because apparently
it sells like go I mean they sold almost
two million copies in three days I'm not
afraid
you understand I'm not afraid
you know why you say Mitch think about
that it would be it would be two months
[Music]
I say I say by animal crossing anywhere
from 17 to 25 million and I say when
cyberpunk launches is gonna make those
two to three million three days look
like Bill Ford your personal pity from
what you see who you think's within this
so I'm not even playing this one both my
kids are and here's what I would watch
it for both of your kids hold on hold on
broken Tendo sales records and it's not
as
it's not a Margaret it's not a Pokemon
title and it's still broke in gender
everybody's stuck at home boy look I
appreciate the bravery in this is what
I'm gonna say right now when people is
being frugal with a bucks because of
what's going on hopefully by the time
cyberpunk is launched we are getting
back to normal so people will have their
look because the economy will start to
come back and people want to get to
normalcy and that will probably be
normal game everybody don't be a part of
that people braving the apocalypse to
play a double-crossing I hate all of you
guys know the power of Phil and you know
this really should have no connection to
exports but somehow you've done this oh
no you know what you know what it a lot
of things shouldn't have a connection to
Xbox but i'ma tell you right now that
Summer Jam screen has been shown
he took a time out to do something and
he don't normally do he did beatrix for
it I want like a big enough one of those
rotating things that can't be putting
statues online I want my neon back you
know what it is everybody knows that I
haven't been wrong with this game pass
stuff so I'm good that I'm glad that I
have sprinkled that on y'all all right
so I'm glad that John got the sprinkle
sauce on you but now they just say y'all
buying into my craziness woman
again that's such a huge magnet will be
months removed except the game pass
that's the power of gamepad I see it
working chat we gotta ask you put a what
if you think add its banana you put a
two if you think King Lord let me let me
let me let me say one more thing about
that whole thing right yeah
did um Phil Dominus Maximus spins to say
what when you purchase cyberpunk one
time that you go get in the series a
series tell you right now I'm telling
you I'm smelling and if they pass your
mind I've seen ones what was the one to
his kick I've said to put three it's for
the kids you know why I'm telling you
you in trouble
it's gonna be on PlayStation 4 who's
gonna be on xbox if you get that game
pass you're done raise viruses will put
a special box for your knees achievement
box
I predicted it so far out mean this mean
is some particle and all right
Oh raid rage virus could put his knees
in a box with you I'll just finish tags
we gotta go yeah I enjoyed it you know
bobble eyes was great we see the DLC
shout out to 2k games supporting a lot
of the switch bodycheck shock and all
that stuff
huge huge huge titles of course the next
card I like to see it there oh yeah it
was good it's just what Nintendo does
and I'm very curious to see moving
forward with our Microsoft and Sony
being that here in the climate that
we're in if we get these style of
presentations now moving forward cuz
obviously we know to e3 thing and that's
it but oh we got to get out of here so
we got to get the poles and get out of
here so uh no ILP poll with the initial
announcements of project s cloud xbox
backward compatibility and game past
ultimate being staples moving forward
with the next generation series X which
of these features do you think is the
most important for the success of Xbox
in the next generation the choices are a
project X cloud will hit markets
traditional Xbox consoles would never be
able to reach prior build was in my mind
go option B Xbox back competitor
critical to DP generations of the Xbox
ecosystem unified and moving forward or
C game path is the best deal in gaming
plus Xbox exclusives day and date and
our final chance of four choices deep I
don't care your friend or VR and AR with
that hololens though when it goes up on
twitter lord build still will of the
cognition team hey let's add ARB are an
absolute pleasure to have you back in
the room where can define people find
you what you have going on sir me and
first off it's been great to be back to
what we went far too long this time in
between yes
life moves fast when you're when you're
busy I guess but you can find me at at
WC still well cuz I'm officially William
Charles still thorough on Twitter and
that's the best place to stay in touch
with what I'm working on what
doing and other than that you know keep
keep looking out for news absolute
pleasure man it's always good to have
you back in the round keep continuing on
with your journey it's so cool to see
your growth to see your development to
see you take on these new projects and
it's it's cool to see Microsoft retain
quality talent you know I'm saying good
dude true gamer can't wait to see the
next things you guys got cooking up I'm
our salute to the Great Wall himself my
bear [ __ ] absolute pleasure to have you
back in the realm and Lord addict in the
realm being extra feisty bringing back
Brendan to me and all this good stuff
wicked a popular fashion but you got
going on sir well I mean you could find
me yet in about November December
collecting TV you can find me on Twitter
and Lord on YouTube at gaming addict I
might start streaming here soon I don't
know yet I got some stuff I have to get
through but you don't want to thank
everyone for coming I want to thank Lord
bills so what because I was definitely
appraiser having the conversation sorry
I was late I know everyone you do
overslept yeah I can't help lord Cognito
do I rarely overseas I think the whole
year
no I did one other time appreciate you
know we'll see you next week I might not
I don't know we'll see sovereign in the
realm talking that talk breaking the
tech down the single player exclusive
Lord wicked if I people find what you
got going on so first off big shout out
to know it still well for coming the
rest of the Lord to God a chance to meet
or still well before I finally got a
chance to meet him at last e3 fantastic
individual and just absolutely like to
see just to see the joy on his face when
we finally got to play X cloud and my
reaction again I remember a cog was
playing Halo and I looked at it and as
soon as I just saw the speed of what was
going on on that little phone I said oh
no oh no I got looked at him he was a
smiling yeah they're amazing yeah that's
basic mmm
right that's fantastic so absolutely a
pleasure to have you on the show again
and yet you guys can find me on be exile
sovereign on PSN and Xbox Live and of
course though it's Saab IOP on Twitter
yes absolute pleasure Lord again in the
room
bringing the face this branding me has
returned the only one that does been the
knee what's on the line honestly well
the bet that you may take er how much
risk taken Lord King is he bet that
PlayStation would not have any backwards
compatibility after they announced that
they would have they have back pack you
gonna pay for it you gonna swipe your
card on the side of the body was not
their line was if they're gonna charge
you or not the initial bet when you
brought it up and I said you sure you
want to do this King I told them I said
King shout the shrewdest wrong opened up
Kings third eyes that your third eyelid
that's the tea that they have when they
pass out inside the game listen I told
you hey listen man it's wizard tree what
we saw when we saw back a patent I'm
telling you is wizard tree
easy right and I know for a fact they
didn't own a lot of unstable things that
doesn't let me know okay well anyway
back to jump all into muster I was
thinking about doing this week y'all
pick a statue right
because I got I got a boy i got a I got
a time I got to do um but I can say this
right the next step being selfish about
it because I don't care about y'all I'm
just joking um but is one statue that I
have to do because there's a huge story
that goes with it and every time I want
to do something I got a gladiator Hulk
respect it it's it's it's decisive that
juggernaut that I have the Reyes is a
huge statue but I have to get this
statue out because it represents me and
my grandmother and you know my
grandmother passed away so and I know
you're trying to figure out like how
does a statue represent your grandmother
when I tell you you can see is the next
Kos okay
alright um you can find me a king David
OTW on Twitter you can find me at Kos
we're not doing no combats talk with the
King right now because of what's going
on and I don't do speculation my combat
talk is not speculation talking all that
other stuff
even though Tyson Fury looks like he's
going to jail yeah you know for shout
out to fighting a way to get in trouble
when you get that's another story
the greatest the greatest one of the
greatest MMA fighters - just throw stuff
away stupidity but I want to give a
shout out to Bill
Lord bills still the Great Wall of Bill
whoa when we go to these events right
we're really like we go from place to
place we very rarely go out to see any
form of LA if we initially get there we
see the Cali team you know go to their
house or whatever see them you know meet
up but we really at the compound -
Convention Center to the convention from
work to work and shout out to Lord Bill
if I actually allow me to you know get
the invite to see some form of Cali - to
- to go to a historic place and I
appreciate you for that because that's
not something that you had to do there's
something that you wanted to do and
you're genuine person facts and
I truly appreciate you with all the
stuff that you have done and even you
know when we was fledgling you know just
coming about um you saw something in us
and I appreciate that like you still
took the time out to to wait for us for
the X cloud stuff and people don't
understand you are real dude facts and
the fact that real people are working at
a company that I love and I know you by
name enough sat with you we broken bread
um you know little things that you take
in its life I've taken that and I
appreciate you for that thank you sir
and thank you for coming back on and I
said no but you know a good friend of
mine who I've coached with in hockey for
years we work together Microsoft their
kids go to school together earlier this
month he had a stroke and brain aneurysm
they passed beginning last week and and
and we've all been there with that
moment where you say to yourself
I missed an opportunity to tell him how
much he meant and so one of the things I
try to do I love what you guys do for
the community I love that we're part of
a bigger thing than any one product or
any one game or any that kind of stuff
you getting out in front of the public
you speaking your mind you showing what
you care about I think we need more and
more of that and I've been reflecting
especially over the last week like you
got to stay in touch with the people who
matter in your life because they're not
always gonna be there and even if it's
just a casual encounter you don't know
how much that casual encounter can lead
to down the road look at this like we
didn't know each other at all we just
happened to happen to cross paths at one
point because we shared a passion for
one thing yes and it's turned into this
and it's turning like what you guys have
done what the community's done take the
time out especially as we're in
quarantine to tell people exactly like
it means a ton that you'd say that you
can't like it means a lot to hear other
people appreciate what you put in the
community take your time and tell
somebody this week that maybe you
haven't talked to in a while or maybe
you haven't ever told them how much they
mean to you you mean something to me and
let them know because you never know
when they're gonna be gone no it's well
spoke said and I'll jump in too because
one of the things that I appreciate that
you do on Twitter is that kind of
appreciation thread thing that you do
and it's kind of like a weekly thing and
you say hey I want to give a shout out
to this concentrator or this person and
again it's like that expression you know
you want to give people the roses when
they can smell them and that's amazing
again we really appreciate what you do
for the community again believing in us
as well in a fledgling state like King
said it's just tremendous to see you
know your growth in everything that's
going on especially in this climate we
need that kind of stuff so iron Lords
Tulum any obviously you know I'm saying
to you Lord Bill in the community it's
been really cool and always always a
pleasure to have you in the round sides
it's always a good time we get to talk
games so yeah that's all I got like I
said please catch up most gave me that
net we got some fantastic articles up
right now we got the HPV our stuff we
got obviously you know if they'll still
hasn't announcement if you want to learn
more about that please go to Lords of
gaming dotnet
you know I'm saying of course the Final
Fantasy 7 thing please everybody enjoy
your sunny thanks for hanging out with
us really cool
that's all I got if anybody got anything
else we are out of here you know get
some cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]